now spill
1172 and you did fill out a pin card
right I
did oh yeah that we yeah
okay you can you can worry about the pin
card later just anybody else has got a
pin card please send them forward do
just bring them bring them over here and
we'll bring you
know I don't want to get too far
behind
okay great all right so I will hear
from the sponsor representing
them
good morning and welcome to the Commerce
Committee good morning Mr chairman and
good morning committee members thank you
for considering your this test this
legislation today my name is Alison NAB
I am the state rep for Rockingham 12
which is strum New Hampshire over in the
Sea Coast um this bill is is being
introduced out of concerns of
constituents in stratum um I have
several constituents that form a condo
association in town that represent
several Condominiums condominium areas
and they had two concerns with the RS
around meeting noticing as written um
the first is the requirement for Condo
Association meetings which is currently
10 days there was concerned about that
being too long of a noticing period um
for condo associations to be able to
make decisions so the legislation as
written would amend that to a 5-day
notice period for condos where 70% or
more of the residents are full-time
residents of the of the
condos um they had originally proposed
24 hours which I think is probably a
little short for condo associations so
the five-day noticing period for
associations where most of the residents
are full-time um seems appropriate their
other concern was the language in the
RSA as it stands uh is a little gray
around whether what's that
oh it's a little gray as to whether um
Committees of the association also are
subject to the same noticing
requirements and I know there's some
debate as to whether that's unclear or
not they feel that it is and these are
people that want to be following the RSA
to the letter of the law so the change
to the legislation would allow for
Committees of the association to not be
subject to the same noticing
requirements so long as they're not
taking action signing contracts this
would allow them to do things such as
meeting with
landscapers um other contractors and I
think this is a good adjustment to
making sure that if you're trying to
make appointments with landscapers and
the like you don't have to say I can't
do it for 10 days from now so it would
allow them to to meet with contractors
and have flexibility around that um so
that those are the proposed changes and
I am happy to answer any questions you
have and I thank you for your
consideration okay any questions from
committee
members just getting arms so so you're
trying to shorten notification
days and and your per reason for
shortening the notification days is 10
days is too much it allows greater
flexibility for condo associations where
um most of the residents are full-time
residents so that's who this would apply
to if 70% or more full-time residents it
gives them more flexibility and in
stratum it's not a tourist town this is
the case most of our condos that's where
they live those are their homes so um I
have a constituent who is going to speak
to this a little bit further the
motivation behind it but that is the the
purpose is to make the notification
shorter
okay fair enough I guess we have no more
questions for you thank you very much
okay so uh Dean who
[Music]
Dean uh lenon in support of the bill
sorry right got 1172 we have
another Gary yes good morning everyone
my name is I am an attorney in New
Hampshire masss focus on
law
with Community associations
ins we support this bill uh because for
the reason stated by the
sponsor um I do think there are good
reasons to have meetings where um
minutes are not required where things
are a little less formal not every condo
is run like 500 company and this bill
reflects that I days
in
mostes
AR
speaking okay any anybody have any
questions oh okay we do have a question
go ahead represent
spear
having lived in a condo once a long time
ago my recollection is 5 days was a
problem only because so many people were
on vacation at various times do you see
that as being a problem I
mean
well let me just pick up on that um this
is condo day and we're going to hear a
lot of different condo issues so in
terms of what you was just saying the
five days if um if there was an issue
that was uh a certain member in the
condo who had strong opinions about it
and if we move it to five days and they
just happen to be on vacation and the
board decides oh great this is our
opportunity to take this issue up while
that person's out of
town wouldn't that be a
problem could
be
turn on your mic
please if the
board was engaged in Shenanigans like
that and they knew Mr Smith was going
away in two weeks they could just
schedule the meeting for then so five or
10 if the board is engaged in these
sorts of shenanigans I'm not sure any
legislation will stop them but the point
my from my perspective most boards are
not involved in anything like that and
they schedule ual meetings when their
members can make it and for no other uh
nefarious reasons so that that concern
representative hunt would would not uh
bother me
personally okay represent
Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking our questions the 70%
threshold um could you just explain
where that number comes from and what
happens if you're below that threshold
well it's not my bill so I don't know
where that number was to derive from um
so I'd prefer the sponsor to resp
respond to that I think the idea was to
uh for communities where most people are
are investor owners or it's a ski or
lake house that it wouldn't apply but
where the 70% came from I can't
say
followup is that the right number if in
your
opinion it it certainly strikes a
balance I think 50% would be too low so
I think something in the range of a
super majority uh does seem
appropriate
okay great thank you thank you uh now
Richard sweat now I got the right
guy good morning chairman hunt and
members of the Commerce Committee my
name is Richard SWAT I reside at 26
Vineyard Drive in stratum New Hampshire
uh my background is I'm a United States
Navy veteran I've had a 33y year career
in the financial services business I've
lived for 16 years at The Vineyards at
stratum condominium this is an over 55
year old Community it's subject to the
provisions of
rsa5 housing for older people I have
extensive experience in condominium
government governance and management I
have 16 years of living in a condominium
six years of service on the board four
years of service as a condominium
president I volunteer on various
condominium committees performing
maintenance services on common area
infrastructure and I participate in the
condominium Leadership Council and thank
you
for hearing my testimony on this bill I
will say that the condomini Leadership
Council in stratum board of directors
support the enactment of HB
1112 we believe the bill will Ex
expedite and improve the efficiency of
board decision making in vetting vendors
and vendor selection the informal
meeting decisions will be acted upon at
the next scheduled board meeting no
votes on Motors on motions will be
permitted now we getting into this 5-day
notice allowing 5day notice before the
board meeting provided that at least 70%
of the unit owners are full-time
residents uh this will allow for greater
board flexibility in scheduling meetings
and more complete agendas uh the notice
of meeting requirements remains
unchanged the notice shall State the
time date place and meeting agenda now
the five-day meeting notice is an
acceptable standard compared to RSA 9A
which applies to meeting notices of
public bodies RSA 9A applies to public
bodies such as Town select boards School
Board zoning boards public bodies
governing large populations and
authorizing the expenditure of public
funds have fewer meeting requirements
than condominium boards the RSA 91 A2
requires a 24hour notice prior to a
meeting and No
Agenda uh the section seven is purposes
to really clarify paragraph one that
implies that all Association committees
are required to follow the meeting
requirements of RSA b37 C uh we're
exempt Association committees from rsab
b37 c meeting requirements if the
association bylaws do not authorize the
committee to spend funds or enter into
contracts Association residents
volunteer to serve on committees if
committees were required to meet the
requirements of RSA b37 C participation
on the committee would be significantly
reduced uh the condominium Leadership
Council and the vineyard Boards of
directors support the enactment of
HB uh 1112 thank you for hearing my
testimony uh the question of
vacations uh at our condominium we have
four quarterly meetings the quarterly
meetings are posted a year in advance
they are in the middle month of the
quarter every resident knows when a
board meeting will take place and can
either schedule their vacation around
that time or not attend at the board
meetings we do open with an open form
for board for Resident members that is
where they speak the rest of the meeting
is closed for the board of directors to
discuss a subject
residents would have to be recognized by
the chairman and the resident would have
to be on a committee that would be
pertinent in Germain to the discussion
at hand uh why five days the reason for
five days is because we uh one of our
members looked looked at RSA 91a and
basically said Gee if these other board
members that are P other boards that are
public only give 24 hours notice why do
we have to give 10 so we settled on five
and that is concludes my testimony thank
you for hearing me
out okay great thank you very much
you're very welcome nice to see you nice
to see you all right I have no more
oh it was Gary I got you Gary sorry one
more card
left good morning and welcome back thank
you uh good morning as well uh my name
is Gary didario I'm one of the partners
at Marcus Rico Emer and Brooks um like
Dean lenon that you heard from a few
minutes ago I'm an attorney who
practices condominium law here in New
Hampshire and um that is my focus all my
clients are condominium associations I'm
here today on behalf of the community
associations Institute they have a New
Hampshire legislative action committee
and uh I presently chair that committee
and I will be brief we support this bill
um as a committee um in general we see
no adverse effects coming from this bill
we don't uh based on the changes that uh
are being proposed we don't see any
problems coming out of it and uh frankly
with respect to um Roman numeral 1 it
seems like it would be very helpful for
boards to have an outlet even if it's
just to do things like compare proposals
that they've received for contracts to
have an outlet where they can meet and
try to be productive and actually get
some of the administrative work done um
separate and apart from all of those
sessions that they're already required
by Statute to have um open with the
community to take ious you know issues
of the community uh Roman numeral one
here would give the board a chance to
work on some administrative items and to
study the paperwork that they need to
study at times when they need to do
something like consider uh their vendor
or the terms of a specific contract uh
as has been mentioned previously um this
bill does not allow them to make a
decision on that contract or to take a
vote on it during that private session
um and so I still think that the balance
is struck in that this bill protects the
community because even after the board
has met to compare these various
proposals and so on there would still be
a vote taken uh relative to that vendor
or that contract at the next open
meeting um so again we we feel like the
bill might have some positive impacts we
don't see negative
impacts great thank you very much thank
you having no more cards on
1172 I will close the public
heing next
one next one is
not
good
you pray sponsor good morning uh good
morning chair hunt and my esteemed
colleagues on the Commerce Committee
it's a pleasure to be here on this snowy
morning thanks for making the Trek to be
here I appreciate you uh my name is
representative Rebecca McWilliams I
represent South conquer um and I'm here
today to talk to you about uh how we
decide uh if we're on a condo board what
kind of energy and what kind of
utilities we are going to be spending
the boards and the everyone on who owns
a condo uh everyone's money on what
we're going to do with energy and
utilities um so as just as background as
you may know um we have had some pretty
severe price spikes in energy both
natural gas and electricity and I know I
have I assume you have as well heard
from constituents that the cost of
energy is just exorbitantly high in New
Hampshire and what can we do as
representatives to address this and try
to mitigate the cost spikes uh and so
this bill is really an approach to
address how do we pivot how do we and
particularly condo owners how do we
pivot and how do we decide okay it's
probably not working whatever energy
source we've selected to use for our
condo how can we change that um as a
collective group um so the intent here
is really to get rid of what I see as an
impediment and a concern um if you have
bylaws for your condo that say you need
a two-thirds majority decision to make a
change and that's pretty common although
it's not the only obviously written uh
requirement sometimes it's uh simple
majority 50% plus one um in very rare
instances it's actually three qus which
is really hard to change your bylaws um
but all of this is to say okay you have
a potential change coming down the
pipeline and you've decided you want to
switch your energy source this is energy
agnostic you want to change to Natural
Gas you want to change to Electric you
want to put in solar you want to change
to propane it doesn't really matter what
kind of energy you as a condo owner want
to switch to the important thing here is
we're trying to stay ahead of the market
and allow uh the condo boards to Pivot
and to change your energy source without
having what I see as a large impediment
to being able to make that change now
I've talked to some folks who um are
very involved with this issue and
there's certainly a concern about when
you have um a large Collective of units
and many of these units are actually
owned by either one person or
potentially by the um the initial
developer of the
development often times the two-thirds
majority is required to make sure that
the developer of the development or a
single owner who owns many many units is
not playing King and making decisions
for the rest of the condo unit owners
and so two-thirds was really meant to be
a protection for everybody to create a
larger um hurdle to make sure that that
this is not being forced upon people but
considering what we've been seeing from
constituents and concerns about energy
prices I would posit that this is
probably not the sort of situation where
we want to force a two-thirds majority I
think that in this case it makes sense
to make it a simple majority 50% plus
one in order for everyone to have an
informed discussion and to vote about
how they're going to move forward and
change energy or utilities um and so
that's the intent of this bill is to
make sure that if and when a condo board
and everyone who owns the condos decides
they want to change energy and utility
is they can do it with a simple majority
50% plus one um so I'm happy to take
questions okay um I guess I'll start
right in
um this statute the 23s obviously is
been controversial over the
years and um and even since we enacted
it when there was a condo re re
reenactment and this got stuck in there
and and uh and I feel like we've had
this issue almost annually about the
two-thirds vote so I guess I'm a little
of concern is that we're chipping away
at this this and say okay but there's
one thing we're going to say it's okay
that the two-thirds won't happen and
that would be setting a precedent now
for people to then say but we got this
issue and we got that issue we got these
issues and that issues and before you
know it we've undermined the whole
purpose of this two3 you know the super
majority to uh have the
the any of these votes taken so I
guess uh do you do you understand that
the the committee should be show be
extremely concerned to just pick one
issue like this issue today and I don't
even know whether this has actually been
a problem in the past but to pick this
one issue now is setting a precedent
that we'll then have um uh every year
we'll have people come in and say well
we want to add another item to this
exemption thank you so much for the
question chair hunt um let me just start
by saying uh I understand that this
could be precedent setting I get it um
also I think we're in a bit of an
emergency situation uh where people's
hands are tied and they are ready to
change their energy source but they
can't scramble together the correct
2third amount of votes to get there so
they're really tied their next step is
they need to sell their condo and find
somewhere else to live because energy
has become too expensive in what they're
locked in because they don't have the
votes to change the energy source with
their condo board so we're forcing
people to leave their housing rather
than changing their energy source I
think that's kind of a big deal um I
understand the president's setting and
the concern that this is a slippery
slope um I would I would say that that's
our job as legislators uh to determine
where do we draw the line and are there
carve outs that are necessary and I
would say in this case considering the
emergency that we're dealing with I do
think that this is worthwhile for
carving out you may disagree and that's
fine um but I I think that sometimes
something arises to the level of public
concern to the point where we as
legislators need to act and I certainly
understand that this may open the door
to having more people file more bills
next year if the governor were to sign
this into law because of the concerns
about well if they could do it for
energy then can we do it for XYZ can we
do it for other things and that's part
of being legislators is making that
decision as a committee and as a body
what else is the appropriate thing to do
for the people of New Hampshire so thank
you for the
question representa Ammon has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for coming
and testifying and introducing the bill
uh just just reading the language around
the proposed change I have that in front
of me uh it starts out if more than 50%
of the votes are acquired by a single
person after developer control is
terminated then a super majority 2third
is required uh if we carve out uh what
you're
proposing wouldn't that allow
potentially a single person to change
the bylaws and the budgets and the
contracted Property Management because
the beginning of that sentence as of
more than
50% of the votes are acquired by a
single person so that would be a simple
majority potentially by one person is is
do you see that as a potential
problem um thank you representative
Ammon that's an excellent
point um a lot of this has to do with
the number of units that we're talking
about right it's different if there are
100 units than if there are 10 um but
nonetheless if we say 50% of the votes
it could be five it could be 50 are
still belonging to a single person um
then we still have the 2third majority
required to change bylaws but with this
carve out we have 50% plus one so you
have that one person let's say it's a 10
unit just to keep it simple one person
owns five units so they would need to
convince one other unit to get six units
to vote for the 50% plus one majority
got it so the math here is
still you need potentially one person if
they have five plus a friend number six
unit or um if it's 100 units then they
have 50 they would still need to come up
with that additional vote so one person
plus one um the two-thirds majority is
really intended to protect everyone else
but when we're talking about energy I
think we're having some robust
discussions here on condo boards and and
correct me if I'm wrong here but I I
have heard from constituents that this
is a concern that they are locked in to
some something very expensive for their
heating this past winter they'd like to
change and they can't get the votes so I
guess the question is would you see a
potential Amendment um that could
protect that one person having five or
50 units and allow more input from
others without going to the two-thirds
is there a way to come up with better
language for question just to clarify
this does this this paragraph only kicks
in if someone has more than 50% so they
would have to have six out of 10 or 51
out of 100 and so that single person
would have a majority vote and be able
to change these important documents
so yes I think an amendment uh is a
potential remedy thank
you would you believe thank you I would
believe that um and I would be open to
an amendment that addresses that because
I think that's a concern um I also think
that locking in it at 2/3 is too high so
thank you okay representative
txon hi there um so as it happens in in
my world I deal with condo associations
but on the western side of the state so
uh I'm you've described this as a a
crisis people are being forced out of
their homes and I am not
aware in my on the western side of the
state where how are you what percentage
of
Condominiums are operated or structured
in such a way that uh what you choose to
heat who you choose to heat your house
with affects who I choose choose to heat
my house with I'm not familiar with that
are we talking propane or something or
El what what is this heating source that
I'm forced into because the condos that
I'm familiar with in chesher county and
Sullivan County primarily are heated
independently of each
other um thank you for the question
generally this happens when it's a very
large building with individual units
that are all attached or connected as
opposed to Standalone units and the
largest culprit during this past winter
was natural gas so we're talking about
individual buildings or connected
buildings that are all in the same heat
system as as a percentage of homeowners
associ or condo associations in in New
Hampshire
do you think it's 50% or structured that
way or 5% or do we have any idea or
we're just taking a guess I would be
happy to do some research on that to get
you an answer but I can't speak and say
it's X percentage
okay I I I have to admit I agree with
you I thought every condo had its own
meter but evidently you're saying
there's some that don't have separate
meter I mean is this common room space
you're worried about or is it the actual
the all the units really only have one
boiler in the whole building it's not a
question of number of boilers and it's
not a question of individual meters this
is the energy source is it natural gas
is it propane is it solar is it electric
where are we getting our energy from for
the condo and so big picture it's we are
locked into this rate because we chose
this type of energy it's not I spend
more money on mine you spend less money
on yours I set my thermostat at 65 you
set your thermostat at 60 that's not the
issue the issue is overall we are locked
into a specific energy source because
the condo board has decided this is the
energy that we're going to have for our
entire condo unit okay so we do have
another bill that uh we're going to be
talking about the propane
contracts and people feeling locked into
those propane contracts which sounds
like that's more the issue here than
this particular issue because in
generally most condo units do have their
own electrical utility in which you can
then negotiate I guess the wholesale who
you're getting your wholesale from but I
agree with you chair um but I want to be
clear that if you have electric
baseboard heat you're going to be
spending a lot more on your electricity
than if you have some other form of
boiler whether it's oil natural gas or
propane because electric baseboard heat
is the most inefficient type of heat we
have you could switch to something like
a
um heat pump right a heat pump would be
way more efficient correct but big
picture we're talking about something
that's been selected and chosen
typically at the time that the condo was
built so some of these are from the 70s
and the 80s and if they're going to
upgrade they upgrade everyone at once so
we're talking about being locked into a
specific type of energy and propane is
certainly a concern I've heard the
propane concerns but this the intent of
this bill is to talk about energy as a
broad swath and make sure that if the
OWN owners want to switch to a different
type of energy they can and they're not
locked in with something that's
expensive thanks for taking my question
and you had said that there could be an
emergency um in terms of the heating
costs and is there a dramatic difference
between you mentioned the the the
electric heating boards is there dramat
really a dramatic difference between
that and some of the other sources that
would force somebody to
move well
I think this is all anecdotal right I
don't have the data to tell you it's
going to be three times more expensive
to use baseboard heat than to use
natural gas I can't tell you that
specifically I can say that we certainly
have people who purchase a condo and
think that it's a great investment and
they're happy living there until they
get the crazy electric bills when we
have a winter where all of our energy
costs are way out of whack you know
based on International conflicts and
also local supply issues so when that
happens people say what do I need to do
to get my budget on track I probably
need to figure out my energy costs
because that's the bill that's coming
every month and it's way more than I
budgeted for right so if you're using
electric baseboard heat just as an
example that is going to be something
that you can say oh maybe I can switch
to an oil furnace and I can spend less
money on that right that would make
sense because I know that it's an
investment and I will probably save
money down the line based on historical
returns and so I'm not going to play the
role of financial advisor here I'm just
going to say when someone looks at their
own budget and cost and they say wow I'm
spending way too much on electricity
this year I got to do something to
reduce that these are the discussions
we're hearing folks have at their condo
board meeting where they say hey
everybody in this condo is using
electric baseboard heat it's become
phenomenally expensive can we switch to
something else so no this doesn't impact
the whole state and certainly if you are
in a detached condo unit that has its
own Electric Supply and you are able to
choose the supplier and you're able to
choose whether you're doing electric
baseboard heat or some other say heat
pump for your own unit and it's not
controlled by the condo board then you
are not subject to this discussion you
are outside of this bill because you can
choose your own energy source for how
you're going to heat your house your
your condo in the winter this is
specific to when everyone is locked in
we're all using electric baseboard we're
all paying the unfortunately probably
default service rate for that electric
and it's become exorbitant so the goal
here is to allow the switch without
creating another
hurdle okay have more questions
represent Spears next and then we have
representative Su and then we have
representative Herbert
and I could tell you you don't switch
from electric baseboard to a heat pump
system that the condo has to vote for
that change the whole condo will have to
vote to to change the the physical
structure of the building so to
represent 's point where he said he has
condos in his district where people
control their own energy and they can
choose which one they're at that would
be an example where one unit could go to
a a heat pump if that's true and I don't
know if that's true but I'm using this
as an example right I'm just saying
using an example which I don't think it
makes any sense to me because I cannot
imagine that there is a single
condo condos in this state that is using
electric base board and has only one
meter I would guarantee you that any
condo if there are condos out there that
are using electric baseboard which there
could be I guarantee you they have their
own meter for that condo I I want to
explain that this is not about number of
meters every single unit has its own
meter that's intentional every single
unit pays for their own usage that's
intentional what I'm talking about is a
tripling sometimes quadrupling of the
base rate like we all did yes correct
everybody it's it's not about individual
meters and I'm not trying to posit that
there's one meter for 10 units or 100
units that's not what I'm saying what
I'm saying is everyone is committed to a
specific type of heat in in a
self-contained condo unit building that
everyone is all connected they're all in
one building okay they're all using the
same type of heat but they all have
their own meters so they can decide what
they set their thermostats at and they
can decide how much they're going to
spend because they can adjust their
consumption right that's that's the
standard base but when the prices get so
expensive that people are looking for an
alternative to switch to some other type
of energy as a collective all 100 units
in the self-contained building all on
their own meters they're ready to switch
to some other type of energy it takes
2third to say all right we're ready to
go to whatever the source is okay you're
using that example if I have my elect
everyone of them's got the separate
electric bill and they want to change
their wholesale supplier they would not
need a vote they could simply notify the
utility company they want to change
their wholesale supplier and that's what
we're what we we are aware as and being
on this committee is if you were to do a
wholeale change I.E change the actual
heating system yes to each unit yes that
absolutely absolutely requires a capital
structural change to the condos yes and
absolutely that is really radical if you
want to create an exemption for that
because we have bills that say simple
things like uh what was the one we had
uh somebody wanted to put an antenna for
his uh
um what what said uh CB radio no it
what's the what's the other short we
radio we had a building in here that
somebody just want to hang wires for a
short weight radio okay and the condo
associations say you know that that
think has to be approved by the condos
everybody has to agree so if if if
everyone
agrees that they want to get rid of this
electric baseboard and they want to put
in a heat pump system yes you don't
won't need just this little you know I
mean to have this exemption would be
pretty radical that's what it is okay so
that that the assumption would be is
everyone agrees that they would want
that change now if some people want it
and some people don't now you're
radically changing the look of the condo
and that is at the heart of condos which
is that has to be a uniform decision by
all the condo members if they want to
change and put heat pumps on the outside
of all the of of some of them and not
all of them just saying I understand
what you're saying I think we're getting
closer to understanding each other's
intent here with this bill I I think
we're getting very close good so the
point of this bill is that it's energy
agnostic okay it's not just about
switching from baseboards to heat pumps
it's also about whether you want to go
from baseboard to natural gas all right
so you're going to add whole that's that
a baseboard could have gas it could have
oil okay so what you want to say is how
about I just want to change who my
natural gas provider was okay that would
be related to the tank okay if each
condo had its own tank they easily would
be allowed to change out their tanks
without a mo vote from the rest of the
so I think baseboard might be a red
herring in this discussion I was just
saying electric baseboard is the most
expensive okay that that is I don't
recommend it for anyone as an architect
who does construction and projects like
this I would never recommend an electric
baseboard because it's so expensive heat
pump is an alternative if you wanted to
go that route but obviously there are
aesthetic concerns I agree with you do
you want some bulbous things sticking
off the back of your building probably
not and you need to figure out where to
put the condenser units it's a whole
change but if we're talking about
furnaces okay if we're talking about you
want to use gas versus na uh let's say
oil versus natural gas furnace right and
right now you're on electric baseboard
heat you would still need to find
somewhere to put your new oil or natural
gas furnace right and then you're
switching for every unit because they're
individually metered you would be
switching that is a big
change agree 100% so we have
constituents who have sticker shock
right now who are talking about oh my
God how do I get away from this I can't
keep spending this much money on heating
okay and they're looking at these big
changes and saying all right I want to
stay in this condo I want to keep
heating but I can't keep heating the way
I'm heating okay that is the intent of
this bill is to enable that switch and
not make it a 2/3 hurdle in order to do
a big change but obviously yes I agree
with you there are aesthetic concerns
this is this is stuff that condo boards
look at all the time to make the
decision what is appropriate for our
units I would say you could probably do
a ducted rather than ductless minisplit
system so you don't have the bulbous
piece on the outside if you're looking
at Alternatives okay I'm not going to
say that this is black and white but
there are many many options out there
and I don't want to say that this is
about a specific type of energy because
it's not it's about allowing people to
make the choice and make the decision
ision to change thank you got it
represent
spear a a number of the changes that
we're talking about for instance if I as
a unit and it could be in in an attached
condo kind of
thing wanted to put in
solar or if the whole condo wanted to
put in
solar that's a capital expenditure and
to have it be decided by such a small
number of people because the ticker
sticker shock from the
electricity may not be any more than the
sticker shock from the capital
investment they're going to have to make
so I I I'm not clear on why we wouldn't
want to have as much buy into to this as
possible so that the 49% of people who
never voted on it don't end up suing all
over the
place anyway that's I would like to know
why would you
believe thank you for the question okay
uh thank you for the question I I don't
really know what you're looking for in
response from me on that um I think that
this comes down to people making
long-term decisions about their energy
because
it's a very expensive thing to budget
for and it's difficult to budget for
when things change so dramatically year
over year uh so obviously this is a
discussion that would happen at the
condo board level and everyone would
show up to have their voice
heard great thank you um
okay yeah did you fill out a card I'm
not sure I yes I did gave you a we
have you you still want to ask a
question okay um my understanding is the
it's electricity and gas are the two
forms that went up dramatically in terms
of pricing if would it be would it be
worthwhile to have a
trigger in for example U the where I
live it's
gas and and you know it's gone up and
not not something I can't handle it but
it's a lot of people know that the bill
is a lot larger and is if you have a
situation where you have a larger
Condominium
Association three or four buildings you
know a couple hundred of this or that
and but they're all on the same supplier
in our case
gas could you have a trigger point would
a uh a
uh would it be worthwhile to have a a
percentage increase that would trigger
the ability of the association to select
somebody else I think we got the
question um I think that's a really
novel question uh if you're if you're
trying to quantify that that trigger in
terms of price increase and over a
certain duration of time like
understanding our market right now uh we
are typically seeing two changes in
prices there's one in the spring and one
in the fall okay and hopefully the one
in the spring is the decrease and the
one in the fall tends to be the really
big increase at least
historically um so trying to set a
Baseline and saying okay um if
the cost per kilowatt hour were to
increase by 200% or more that is a
trigger for this 51% change potentially
rather than
2third I could see that being a
potential amendment to this bill to
create some sort of mechanism to say
it's become an emergency situation we
are suddenly in a situation where people
are not able to budget for um the crazy
increase in cost and so they're all
feeling the hurt um I I think that that
that's a novel question and it's
probably worth discussing a little
further if there's a way to come up with
metrics I'm just talking off the cuff
because you posited it right now um but
I do think that there may be some way to
come up with um some protection around
that I understand the chair is very
concerned about a slippery slope and
opening the door to more and more people
trying to get a reduced vote uh
threshold um but I think we we as
legislators are legislators we as people
who are elected to serve our
constituents need to be sensitive to the
needs of our constituents specifically
when we're all hearing the same thing
about cost and uh Energy prices so there
may be a way to come up with that um I'm
I'm open to further discussion on that
okay you have one more question
representative
Sullivan thank you so kind of to go back
to the the wording of this and I don't
know if you will be the answer or maybe
the chair might know best but um I'm
looking at the the
50% that seems this seems to only be
relevant when more than 50% of the
people or of the vot vot are acquired by
a single person so is this like a real
problem or the majority of condos or
even a sizable minority of condo
associations owned by uh have 50% owned
by um one individual because if that's
not the case it sounds like this is not
relevant unless I'm wrong is it
two-thirds all the time or only under
this circumstance that's sort of my
question well the um
and what did happen yes it was 2/3 the
super majority was put in um and that
was because of attendance for a meeting
and that that if you're see 50% is
implying you know the terms of the 50%
plus one and what if everybody attended
but was more important that was if the
if the vote went down not again again
the most classic example is the budget
itself if the the budget was voted down
um the concern was then
uh now you have put every condo in a
position where they are going to have a
litigation they're going to have a
difficulty def finding the resolution so
that's why the super majority was put in
the two-thirds was put in uh it's been
controversial over the years because
everyone says that's outrageous that you
have to have a super majority to
overturn the budget and that's that's
usually what we've seen in bills in the
past but it was it was uh a policy
decision uh it was worked out negotiated
over a long period of time and the condo
owners agreed and condo agreed that that
was the right answer so yeah so but my
question is it's the way I read this if
more than 50% of the votes are acquired
by a single
person that's when the two-thirds
majority kicks in that single person is
a little misle that's just that's that's
just 50 you know the count what happens
in 50% is
50.5 so that single person language
there is meant to imply with the numbers
we were discussing that if you had 10
condos that means six would would be
what you need so that's that was the the
plus one single person is just an is
just a to handle fractions okay but like
if if is this relevant I guess let's go
to a 10 unit thing is 2/3 required if
all 10 units are owned by 10 different
people sounds like 2/3 is not required
in that situation right so so if all 10
people have 10 separate units right okay
then it's just a 50% plus one no ex
provided that so in other words that um
uh the majority vote would would be
required um the that that paragraph
excuse me that's the language of the
bill um that it was intended that um 2/3
was for anything that you were changing
budgets bylaws yeah that's not how I
read it that's why I'm a little confused
uh like well okay we can hash it out
another time it just seems like it only
when there's a a majority ownership by
somebody there majority the majority the
Assumption was the majority was written
in most by laws and then we rais it to
2/3 but I agree you the way it's written
it seems a little awkward but basically
yes 2/3 is pretty much everything that
the so a majority vote um is uh the
majority vote is everything uh but
bylaws budgets and
contracts is majority vote but if it's
bylaws budgets or contracts with
property management then it has to be a
two-thirds
vote okay representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chairman um my
question is basically to to clarify
because I I got a little bit confused by
what was just just said um so I'm going
to try and clarify with a concrete
example which happens to be my own I
live in a condo development with 200
units okay more than half of those units
are owned by one entity I'm not sure
whether it's a corporation or an
individual human but I don't think it
would matter so under those
circumstances to change the bylaws we
would need a 2third vote but the
question then is if all of those 200
units were owned individually that is
there was no majority
owner could the bylaws be changed if we
chose to do it that way uh under statute
could the bylaws be changed by a
majority vote thank
you I I guess I'll have to ask the
lawyers but they'll come up and they'll
clarify this for for you just okay thank
you very much thank you for your time
all right
Dean we're missing the
card yeah okay good morning again Dean
Lennon for the community association's
uh Institute um I think we started off
today being neutral on this I think I'm
I'm far more um against at this point um
to answer representative Gibb's question
it's going to come down to the condo's
governing documents um sometimes it's a
majority to amend bylaws sometimes it's
2third uh you know this this uh existing
uh Bill
uh requires the two-thirds
if half the units are owned by a single
person and and to address representative
Sullivan that's exceedingly rare in my
uh experience it's exed except it occurs
in hers yes yeah okay so why don't you
answer her question what exactly if they
were to change in her condos given that
one half 100 of them are owned by the
developer probably she would need the
two-thirds
vote but what if they were all owned
individually then we could decide for
ourselves whether we wanted 2/3 or
simple majorities it depends what you're
existing documents say no I understand
that but if we chose to have our
documents could we under statute make it
a simple majority yes thank you
yes so I I think if we just assume
there's an issue with heating costs and
people being priced out we'll just
assume that to be true I don't think
this legislation fixes the issue uh
because most of the we don't see this
issue first of all because if you're
going to go from baseboard heat to forc
hot air or something like that it
doesn't matter go from A to B B to C it
doesn't matter just pick pick your
uh your type of of heat it's such a
profound change that it's just never
going to happen you're talking about
ripping things out of walls you're
talking about installing things on the
exterior these are things that condos
don't do they have what they have and
they deal with it and I think the answer
is what what representative hunt said
and that's to switch your your carrier
uh or your supplier uh maybe uh you get
a discount from B but not from a so you
go with b and that's a board vote you're
not amending your documents to switch
from one type of uh heating or one
utility to another that's not how you
would do it in my opinion it would be an
improvement an improvement is something
new so you have grass you want to
install a tennis court that's not
something a board can approve because
it's something brand new it's not
maintenance or repair ha it's
something that wasn't originally
contemplated so if you're going from
electric baseboard heat to propane heat
to me that's an improvement because it's
something that doesn't currently exist
and usually under your docks anyone
docks that's going to be a majority vote
uh but I think if it's not a majority
vote if it's a two-thirds vote that's
appropriate because you're not going to
go from A to B without forcing owners to
buy a whole bunch of stuff that's
incredibly expensive so if they're
having trouble affording uh their
utility bills they probably don't have
the money to buy a bunch of new
equipment to switch over to the new
source of energy you just
can't go go from Electric to propane
without
infrastructure and that's the other
issue here is do we want a simple
majority
forcing duck work to be installed on the
outside of condos or uh heat pumps on
the exterior some people don't mind the
look some people do so I think if we're
if it is a two-thirds Vote for This sort
of thing uh it's an appropriate
um hurdle to to cross because we're
talking about something so
transformative for a
condo and I I think uh you know
just uh representative Hunt's comments I
think struck to the core of the issue
and from my perspective our committee
supports his uh
Outlook question from the committee yes
representative M uh thank you chairman
um thanks for taking my question I I
just wonder if this whole thing is even
necessary why why not just go by the the
documents of that particular uh condo
unit which may say 2third may say a
majority I I just find
this unnecessary yes with respect to the
the sponsor I also find it to be
unnecessary it's incredible L specific
legislation and it opens the door to
another interest group trying to carve
out their piece I I I too find it to be
uh unnecessary and to Sol uh
representative Sullivan's point it's
just this is not going to cure a problem
because most condos don't have a single
majority owner some do most do
not okay thank you for your time thank
you do anybody else would like to
testify uh oh okay
okay all right because you were in the
room when it
happen hi uh for the record again Gary
didario um testifying on behalf of the
community association's Institute
legislative action committee for New
Hampshire um I think a lot of the
confusion today is that we're talking
about the wrong SE of the statute we're
talking about section 39 today a
potential amendment to section 39 and as
was pointed out by representative hunt
uh representative Ammon uh if I got your
name right I hope uh and uh
representative Sullivan's question uh
all go sort of to the heart of the
matter from a statutory perspective the
section that we've been talking about
this morning is the section that is
there for those rare situations when
there's a concentration of power at the
association meaning that one individual
or one corporation owns more than 50% of
the units that's why that section starts
out that way um and as long as we're in
section 39 that's sort of the situation
that we're trapped in because that's
what section 39 does IT addresses what
happens when there's a concentration of
power a lot of questions uh have have
gone towards the issue of well what
happens when that's not the case what
happens if we just have a normal quote
unquote normal condominium where um you
know units are owned by all different
people or to the extent that someone
owns a couple of units it's not
consequential and it doesn't bring us to
section 39 uh the answer to that
question is that it's section 34 of the
existing statute is where amendments in
general are discussed and so if you
didn't have a concentration of power at
your condominium and you were
considering amending things you would be
at section 34 not at section 39 I think
that's where the the confusion
is great now does this section 34 still
have this thing about the two-thirds
vote for Budget it does it does um and
and uh to that I would Echo uh the
comments that Dean lennin just gave you
and that I think some of you have have
touched on as well um which is that for
such a massive undertaking um I think
the legislature got it right in looking
for the super majority of 2/3 because um
at an association if
51% said we're switching from Electric
to oil then the other 49% which is a lot
of people get dragged along into an
expense where you're ripping out the
electric stuff you're buying oil tanks
you're you're installing whatever
equipment is going to run off oil um and
that's just sticking with this example
in general when you're amending your
documents it it could be extremely
important because you could be talking
about any issue that affects your
Association but to the extent that
you're making that type of fundamental
change because when you buy into a
condominium you are in the first place
agreeing to live as a member of a group
uh it's appropriate that if a major
change is being made that it takes a lot
of that group to want to head in that
direction that that just makes sense in
general good thank you very much Gary
thank thank you okay having no more
cards cards we will close the public
hearing and now we have another another
Public Utility Commission okay
okay so it is some time so represent on
us sorry about our delay here but I'm
sure you found the previous discussion
very helpful and understanding how
condos operate I I did your Mr chair um
I welcome the discussion my name is Zoe
Manos I represent stratum which is down
near
Portsmith and I'm very pleased to be
here I'm a freshman so this is the first
bill that I have uh sponsored and
introduced and so uh I'm very excited to
do this um so this bill would enable
non-commercial condos and I want to
emphasize that it's non-commercial non-b
buus condos to receive res residential
electric rates this bill applies to the
condo association as the electric
consumer um and not to individual
homeowners of course are entitled to
receive residential electric rats so
this would apply to the condo
association um itself as a an electric
consumer um this bill uh assures equity
for condos so that common expenses such
as lighting well pumps septic systems
and laundry
facilities um are for common expenses
are treated as residential rather than
um at commercial rates which are
generally
higher um this bill was requested by my
constituents from stratum there's a
condo Leadership Council in stratum um
Mr SWAT is here and he will be
testifying uh on my bill
and I welcome your
questions thank you for your testimony
and uh I see representative
burrow thank you for taking my question
and congrats on your first fail here
thank you um my question is is this a
common practice to have residential
units get that differential um and be
charge the the business rate uh right
now it's my understanding and it's my my
constituent's experience and and my
constituent is the there's an
association of condo associations in
stratum so there are multiple condos and
stratum and their experience is that
they are completely residential but they
are being charge commercial electric
rates followup and not residential
rates is is that even
legal uh apparently it is Mr SWAT will
testify more about this but they had uh
multiple discussions with the Pu with um
with the regulatory entities and they
were told repeatedly that they are not
entitled that they must be build at the
G2 rate and not at residential rates
thank you very much representative
suin uh thanks for your testimony so
just to be clear I'm G to follow up off
of her because I understood what you
said a little bit differently are you
saying that the individual private
residential unit is being charged
commercial or just the common spaces are
being charged at the commercial just the
common okay all right excuse me just the
common spaces individual unit owners are
are clearly entitled to a residential
electric rate all right
thanks any other
questions represent
Ammon thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking our questions I'm just
looking at the text of the bill and the
Bold section which is the the new
language
and it
says and whether any commercial or
business enterprises are permitted so
help me understand how that that small
change accomplishes your goal are there
commercial Enterprises sometimes run out
of the common spaces that we were
discussing just help me understand that
that uh that's that phrase I I'd be
happy to answer your question my
intention here was that commercial
Condominiums so for example condominiums
that have the barber shop in it and the
restaurant in it and bus cond business
condos
exactly would this bill does not apply
to business condos it applies to
condominiums that are strictly
residential so if I decide to have a
business in my
barn shouldn't I I say well you give if
you if we were to pass this bill
couldn't I then say well we should they
anybody in New Hampshire who has a
business Enterprise on their property be
able to be
residential thank you for your question
um I think in general um and I I don't
know of any exceptions that residential
Condominiums do not allow individual
unit owners to conduct business out of
their individual units and so the
example you gave of the barn would not
be
applicable right no that's true that
part it I was just saying is that if
if if it's a business like if you have a
barber shop assume that's a tenant you
know the barber is paying rent and
that's a tenant that sure sounds like a
business to me yes but that would be
done in a condominium that is strictly a
commercial
condominium with
multi that is a commercial condomini so
that one's commercial so we're talking
about the hallways open space we're
talking about the hall things that were
not necessarily uh commercially Revenue
generating okay I misunderstood you all
right great thank you representative
Sullivan has a question yeah so I mean
I'm supportive with what you're trying
to do I'm not sure if I read this
language as accomplishing that but maybe
I'm wrong but it see like I get what
you're trying to do but this doesn't
sound like it clarifies it but maybe
somebody else here has a different read
on this but I'm just wondering if maybe
this langu if I'm if people agree with
me on this maybe this language isn't
right and maybe there's an amendment
needed or a clarification
needed I don't know that's just sort of
a what you believe well I would
certainly be open to Amendment and to
working with you and the committee on
amendments to
it okay representative M oh thank you um
a
question it's not by law that utilities
can charge the commercial rate is that
correct they can or they can't my
question is will why can't a Condominium
Association uh go to another electric
provider and say hey they're charging us
commercial will you charge us
residential and there's different
providers out there why can't they just
negotiate that
themselves I think Mr sweat can can
offer more direct information on that
because he's had the experience with
going through this process to try to get
residential rates for the Condominium
Association but my understanding is in
our area it's Unitil who's our default
uh electric company and when the
Condominium Association um approached
Unitil and said we would like the
residential rate they were told no they
could not they had to stick with the
commercial
rate okay yes representative em has
another question thank you uh just one
one last question thinking about the
last few words of uh the new section
there it says
uh that do not permit commercial or
business enterprises shall be charged
the same electric rates as condominium
residential units and in our previous
bills discussion we were talking that
different units can re can have
different rates right the the owner can
sign up for different services so which
which residential units provided that
they could have different rates which
ones would uh they be required to to to
give may I just have a moment to read
the language here shall be charged the
same electric rates as condominium
residential
units um again maybe this needs
clarifying language because
obviously
um individual unit owners can as as was
discussed earlier can choose their own
supplier and Community Powers coming
forward and so that choice can be made
but the intention of the language here
is that um commercial rate versus
residential rate not commercial rate
versus having no choice on the
residential rate okay
does that answer your question I I I
think it's it may need some
clarification on in the language but I
understand the intent thank you about
swimming
pools what what about swimming pools is
swimming pools common
space um I I think so yes I mean some
some condominium because they can use a
lot of electricity right yes but again
it's for a a swimming pool is limited to
the unit owners and their guests and
families it's not open to the public got
like the barber shop correct okay
correct
wowe
okay any other
questions thank you very much thank
you Mr sweat I know you would like to
speak but I have someone here who has an
opinion you might want to hear first
before you testify so uh chair will'll
call on Griffin Rober from the New
Hampshire energy
Department thank you uh Mr chairman
members of the committee uh for the
record Griffin robers I am the state
energy program manager at the New
Hampshire Department of energy and
currently working its way around the
room is a letter of testimony from the
Department on this bill um for the
record the department is opposed to this
bill as introduced um looking at the
bill section one um which is lines one
to four require declarations for every
condominium to include a description or
delineation of The Limited common areas
that any uh showing or designating the
unit or units to which each is assigned
and whether any commercial or business
enterprises are permitted and then
section two requires condominium
associations do that do not permit
commercial or business enterprises shall
be charged the same electric rate as
condominium residential units
condominium uh associations may have
common areas or jointly used facilities
served by an electric meter or uh
numerous meters electric service to
these common areas or facilities
provides a benefit beyond that provided
to an individual home or residence as
such the use of electricity in common
areas or common facilities is not
residential in nature and thus the
service provided is appropriately
classified as non-residential or
commercial New Hampshire's Electric
utilities classify service strictly in
commercial or residential terms with
different rate options available within
each broad rate rate class the Bill's
language before you would permit
condominium associations across the
state to delineate their limited common
areas and determine whether any
commercial or business enterprises are
permitted in those areas an electric
utility would then be required to
provide service under its residential
rates to any common areas that do not
have business or commercial Enterprises
as written the uh Department believes
passage of this bill would have several
unintended consequences um the Bill
permits condominium associations which
has been discussed are commercial
entities to determine whether business
or commercial Enterprises take place in
common areas on their property as a
result condo associations rather than
the electric utility would have the
authority to to determine the rate
classification that they fall under and
they would pay that to their uh utility
Service as a result of that shift in who
determines the appropriate rate utility
there is the potential for the under
recovery of costs by the utility and the
shifting of costs between residential to
non-residential
customers uh final point is the bill
inappropriately shifts the determination
of an appropriate rate from the utility
to the customer themselves allowing a
Condominium Association to choose what
rate it wants to take service under
meters that serve common use areas or
common facilities are appropriately
classified as providing commercial
service to condom condominium
associations because condominium
associations are commercial entities uh
because condominium associations are by
natur commercial entities the service
provided to those common areas or common
facilities is treated as such and they
are charged non-residential or
commercial tariff rates for those that
for that commercial service um with that
that closes my testimony uh happy to
answer any questions that folks might
have but I do want to note I do not live
in a condo association I I could not
come close to talking about um Condo
Association law uh but more than willing
to try to answer as much as I can so but
you're the enforcer of this of this
section the statute so swimming
pools swimming pools are they in or
out thank you for the question so it
would depend based on the language of
this bill is that it well I forget about
the bill I want to know current law I
assume I assume swimming pools would be
considered common facilities common use
areas and my mind they're not considered
residential in
nature okay so in your mind this bill is
uh somewhat conflicting to way the law
is structured and which is obviously why
the bill is in front of us is that uh
they don't
like this current law
yep okay representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair uh and thank
you for coming to testify uh I live in a
condo association um and we have some
common use areas a community room a
fitness room um a swimming pool and
tennis court all of those are restricted
to use by condo owners or people who are
renting from condo owners essentially
people who live within the condo
units wouldn't it be different if for
instance the condo
association were say
renting out the community room for other
events for weddings or other types of
events that would clearly be a
commercial Enterprise so isn't there a
diff
differentiation between that commercial
situation and the situation that we
actually have in our condo development
where essentially we have a communal
living room and a communal swimming pool
and so on uh which is not available to
the public never rented out to
anyone isn't that different and wouldn't
it be appropriate under those
circumstances to have a differentiation
in the electric rates sure thank you no
thank you for the uh thank you for the
representative question thank you for
the question representative um I I
understand the point of the question but
I guess I guess I'd like to raise two
points is the first one is you are
allowing a certain commercial entity a a
Condominium Association under this bill
to delineate where business or
commercial activities take place on
their property um condo associations are
by Nature commercial I mean I there's
not going to be a person who walks into
the community center as you that you
mentioned representative to determine
okay today it's being used for a
commercial use tomorrow it's going to be
used for residential um it is a it the
bill in essence is a is a in our opinion
a significant granting of power to a
specific subsection of a commercial of
commercial entities to allow them to
choose what utility rate classification
they fall under and that is that is
problematic to impose especially on a
Statewide
basis for question you may inquire yeah
thank you uh but in the situation I was
describing where most of the time the
community room is used just by the
residents but sometimes um it might be
rented out for a wedding
say what's going to happen there isn't
that exactly the situation that you said
would never happen that is somebody is
deciding presumably the condo board um
when it's commercial and when it's not
that is it's clearly commercial if it's
being rented out for a wedding but is it
commercial if it's our communal living
room if the thank you for the question
so simply put if the property is owned
by a commercial entity such as the condo
association then that area is deemed
commercial and they pay a commercial
rate um you know individuals and condos
might have their own individual meters
for their own condos and they most
likely would be paying the residential
rate but those common areas where there
are certain commercial activities taking
place whether or not one is uh paying
condo dues and that type of thing um by
Nature these condo associations are
commercial entities and therefore they
should be paying the commercial rate
okay representative bars
no no you're you were going like this is
it a faction
yes thank you for taking my question um
I guess what I want to know is do you
think that an amendment could be put
forth that would um set forth the
parameters like in the situation that
representative gives gave I mean there
are some condos they have common living
area that or as she said they're not
used for any commercial purposes could
could we set up parameters that would
clarify so it's not solely at the
discretion of the condo or or the uh
electric electric company sure and thank
you for the question so I would say
could an amendment be offered sure this
is the committee to do that and each of
you is entitled to draft any Amendment
you want um you know if somebody is if
there is an association you know I guess
the suggestion about a potential
Amendment we'd like to see any type of
language um before making any sizable
comment but again by nature this is
giving a certain section of commercial
entities the ability to choose the rate
classification that they fall under and
that is quite unprecedented um you open
the door here where does it stop don't
be surprised if other leg if future
legislators see other bills come forward
and say maybe we want one for this this
commercial entity this commercial entity
is commercial entity and then to um the
question that I heard representative
melier I hope I'm saying that correctly
um mentioned earlier is that commercial
entities um as well as residential
entities um are able not to just get
their power from their default service
supplier which it could be Unitil
eversource Liberty Utilities they can go
out and solicit a competitive electric
supplier and by going out and seeking a
competitive electric supplier some of
those suppliers might have lower rates
if the concern here uh from the
constituent and I I I will admit I did
not know this was a specific constituent
issue but if the concern is about um any
specific um increase in electric rates
or anything like that there is the
option out there for consumers both
residential and Commercial to shop
around and find a more competitive rate
that might potentially be lower rather
than going to default service um sorry I
kind of segue into his question from
earlier but I hope that answers your
question representative Herbert and
you're G to make it short and sweet
would would it be would it be accurate
my observation would be is that things
like pools larger common areas uh are
more expensive and that's what is
bothering the
utility because in effect you've got a a
facility that is expensive to have sure
and you don't want to pay the bill sure
and oh sorry they don't pay bills you
pay
them no I'm yes
okay so
so uh yeah okay represent
no very briefly um if this bill were to
pass what would the enforcement
mechanism look like how difficult would
enforcement be let's let's say they
claim a condo claims to not rent out a
room but in in in reality they are
renting it out who would enforce that uh
statute thank you thank you for the
question you know it's not abundantly
clear at the department we don't have
people going around knocking on doors
and you know what rate classification
are you following um I'm assuming that
would be something that the electric
utilities would certainly be involved in
uh for sure um but obviously if the if
the statute under this bill allows condo
associations the the ability to choose
that rate classification for their
common areas they're entitled to do so
if it becomes
law okay thank you very much thank you
very much all right now sir
uh representative Mr Swit Richard swiat
come on
up I keep thinking of Dick sweat or
Richard
sweat but you are you are not a
congressman Ambassador
right yeah just make sure that mic's on
perfect and you have to pull it pretty
close to you too because we want
everybody at home to hear you okay
perfect well set yeah I've introduced
myself before so we'll get right into
this uh
1430 uh one the purpose is to establish
for our Condominium Association a
uniformity of electric rate schedules
for residential condominiums that do not
permit commercial or business
enterprises to operate presently we have
two rate schedules in our Condominium
Association for the residents they are
in the domestic rate for what
uh I for what was the gentleman's name
here from uh New Hampshire
power what was his
name robt Robert okay well Mr Robert
um Mr Robert's close enough Roberge Ro
Bridge Okay think French ah think French
yes
um
so we have two rates in our
association the domestic rate for
residents and we have the commercial
rate that applies to our pump house that
pumps wellwater to our residents the the
wellwater is used for domestic purposes
we have septic systems that have are on
the commercial rate believe me all the
Wastewater from from those units is
domestic Wastewater it is not commercial
Wastewater we have street lights along
the condominium and they are built at
the commercial rate our position is when
we say uniformity of rates we believe
that as the statute says it the domestic
rate states for domestic use we are of
the opinion that wellwater used by the
residents septic systems that is still
discharge from the residence is domestic
SE Wastewater and street lights are for
domestic use we have no swimming pool we
have no common area for a house or
anything like that so that would be
uniformity of rates uh the determination
for applying electric rate schedule is
based on the fact that the power is used
for domestic residential purposes and
not based on the corporation's
organizational structure the
organizational structure would be the
argument that was made that condom
condominiums by definition are
commercial entities that is not true if
you look at our corporate charter our
corporate charter states that it is for
the welfare the benefit and the health
of the residents of our Condominium
Association there is nothing in there
that says there anything to do with
commercial activities in our
association secondly in the state of New
Hampshire I would be willing to bet that
most condominium associations either
commercial or residential are
Incorporated in fact one of the statutes
says that Condominiums can be
incorporated it is not unusual to have a
condominium Incorporated it is highly
unusual to me to have have to come up
with the concept that because you are
Incorporated you are therefore a
commercial Enterprise I find that one
difficult to believe I support for this
bill is definitely a pocketbook issue
for Condominiums not permitting who do
not permit commercial or business
enterprises residential Condominiums
have pumps septic systems street lights
Etc assign the commercial rate that
would benefit from reduced expenses if
assign the residential rate there's no
question about that uh It is believed
that 1430 would favorably affect at
least 500 or more North New Hampshire
residential
Condominiums I would certainly also say
that we are talking about when we talk
about electric rates you know there are
two
sources of charges in your bill one is
for the electric
charges himself and he is correct you
can go and you can go to North American
power you can go to community power you
can go to any of those other ones and
that will be what you are charged for
your use of electricity what we are
talking about is the delivery charge the
delivery charge uh is a separate charge
and that is what we would like to have
be the residential rate and not the
commercial rate I can tell you that we
have a fire Pond we have our airation
pump in the fire Pond that airation pump
comes out from during the cold months
during the it is assigned a commercial
rate the airra pump in our fire Pond is
is assigned a commercial rate because it
is built to the association which is a
convenient form of having our property
manager pay our bills during the months
when that airra pump is not operating
not drawing a bit of kilowatt hours the
delivery charge because it is based on a
commercial rate is $42 a month if we
were on the residential rate it would be
like $16 a month there is a substantial
difference between these rates and I
certainly understand why the department
of energy would not like to see a change
here now a little bit of History here
back in October oober of 2022 we
contacted Todd Blackman he is the senior
vice president of unel we wrote him a
letter asking him to consider putting us
on domestic rates he assigned that to
Mark Lambert Mark Lambert is a vice
president in charge of billing so he
assigned that to another person who is
in charge of billing we had
Communications with him and he basically
said it is what it is accept what it is
and that is it so we went to the uh
Department of energy and we spoke to uh
Michael CYO uh he could not answer our
question so he moved it up to Amanda
Nunan Amanda Nunan basically said
basically what this gentleman said
because you are Incorporated you deserve
a commercial rate it's because you're
Incorporated that's the reason
I can't accept that I I don't think that
is a reasonable way to look at this
problem so anyway that's what I have to
say the uh vineyard's board of directors
and the condiment Leadership Council
support the enactment of
1430 and I thank you for hearing my
testimony any
questions thank you very much you're
very
welcome chair Colin Gary diduro who is
in opposition to the
bill hi good morning again uh Gary
didario from the Community Association
institutes New Hampshire legislative
action committee um going to stop by
saying that um it's a it's a very loose
uh opposition that we have to the bill
uh as far as the intent of the bill the
idea that a residential condominium
would be charged a residential electric
rate that makes perfect sense um we
support that um that idea again just
makes perfect sense I I don't know that
there's much argument uh against that
and there are certainly those
condominiums that are strictly
residential you just heard from um an
owner who said that his condominium has
no uh pool no common areas for rental
Etc there are many Condominiums like
that um there might be no common areas
there might be just units that are
connected next to each other um all
units uh potentially are occupied on a
residential basis it is very very common
for the condominium instruments to
actually prohibit commercial uses uh of
any kind of the units at a condominium
and so in those instances when you have
a condominium and it's nothing more than
a legal fiction and a type of ownership
and what's going on there are people
just living in their residential units
as their primary and personal residents
um I I don't think there's any reason
why uh they should be viewed as a
commercial Enterprise that's to the sort
of main purpose and intent of the bill
um to the language of the bill itself I
just have one um sort of clarifying
comment to make sort of similar uh to
the situation uh when we were speaking
about the last bill but uh the proposed
amendment would add to subsection e of
section
16i uh this language and whether any
commercial or business enterprises are
permitted and um I just don't think that
that's necessary
um if you stay within 16i but you move
down a couple of subsections if you go
from subsection e down to subsection H
you will find the following language and
this is all pertaining to what needs to
be in the governing instruments section
H says a statement of the purposes for
which the condominium and each of the
units are intended and restricted as to
use so in terms of identifying the uses
of the condominium and the condominium
units um we have that at 16i it's in
subsection H and so um the change to
subsection e to add the language about
stating whether or not commercial
Enterprises are present uh would just be
unnecessary language um so again we
don't disagree with the concept of this
bill um but subsection e uh does not
need to be amended because that purpose
is accomplished in subsection
H okay representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for taking my question um but what
about the condo associations that do
have common areas and going back to my
earlier question isn't there a different
what you've described in subsection H
appears to apply only to units that is
units cannot be used for commercial
purposes um which makes perfect sense
and I suspect there's a similar their
similar language in the basic documents
of my own condo association I also
suspect that our documents forbid
commercial usage of the common areas
such as renting out the community room
for weddings or renting out the swimming
pool for children's parties if that is
the case wouldn't those also be
non-commercial uses that are just as you
might say group residential uses and
therefore appropriately subject to uh
residential rates but wouldn't that
require the uh amendment to subsection
e so uh thank you for your question um
subsection H actually requires the
documents to list the use of the
condominium and of each of the units um
so I think subsection H does cover us at
present meaning that with subsection H
as it exists already in place any set of
condominium documents should include
statements as to the use of the
condominium and the units so I think we
do already have that um and for that
reason I don't think section uh
subsection e needs to be adjusted uh to
answer your question about the
circumstances and whether in my opinion
uh they are residential or commercial I
would agree with you that uh in the
instance you're describing you're
talking about a residential condominium
uh I mentioned earlier that there are
some easy cases where there aren't
common areas or there aren't clubhouses
or swimming pools U those would be the
easiest of the cases uh but if we were
to expand and say that we're looking at
an association that does have a
clubhouse or a pool one or the other
both what have you um I do still think
that there's a difference between
whether that Community is a residential
Community or commercial Community if
everybody who lives there is living in a
personal residence and it's being used
as uh their residential home um then I
don't think that you have a commercial
condominium and in the same way people
with single family homes who enjoy their
own lot of land might have a pool and
that doesn't make them a commercial
venture sure now at their home because
there's a pool in the backyard um I
don't think that change happens at a
condominium either and there are
actually other areas of law uh in which
uh Condominiums are viewed as being
residential or not or whether they pools
are considered public or not uh and for
those purposes they fall sort of within
one bucket of Regulation or another and
if a community is using their pool only
for their community if it is not open to
the general public if it's not rented by
the local high school for swim team
practice or what have you um then that
pool is still considered to be a private
pool and not a public pool and so if
you've got a residential condominium and
there's no business operating on the
property and everybody who lives there
does so for purposes of their residents
and their pool is only used by those
residents of the community who live
there then I I think you're talking
about a residential situation there
doesn't seem to be anything commercial
about
it okay I I hope you understand he's
confirming what you are saying he is but
the reason that I I need to ask a
question is that the state department of
energy representative has just said the
exact opposite that under current law
any common area in a condo association
is inherently commercial commercial
whether it's being used for a commercial
area or not and that being so doesn't
subsection e actually require this uh
amendment in order for those common
areas to be charged the residential rate
because the the uh witness uh has just
said that in his opinion the uh common
area should be charged the residential
rate but the department of energy has
said they should be charged the
commercial rate so wouldn't that require
an
amendment um well he's say he's just
saying he's reading us to the what's the
current law and in your mind that means
to to that given the situation that's
going on now the the law needs some law
not maybe not that one or this one
something needs to be corrected because
of this
discrepancy and so to ask him I guess I
think I can clarify actually okay um so
so this um uh Bill hb1 1430 uh proposes
two changes the first is to 16i
subsection e that's what I've been
referring to in the Condominium Act that
change I don't believe is necessary
because section H again states that
there needs to be a statement of the
purposes for which the condominium and
each of the units are intended uh but
this bill proposes a second change uh
that change is to RSA
378 section
6-a uh and that's where they talk about
the rates and so uh I think that would
still be needed in order to effectuate
any type of change and we don't oppose
that piece so it it it's just to the
extent that I say it's unnecessary I
mean just the first section talking
about the Condominium Act because the
act as it exists already requires a
statement of purpose um but 1430 would
still need to be passed for the second
piece that changes 378 6A that's where
we get into the electric rates thank you
okay
spear the electricity needed to operate
the waste pump the waste uh facilities
to operate the um water pumps that kind
of
thing the residential units could not
even function as residential units
without about that so that's part of to
me the residents and it makes sense that
we do something about allowing that to
be charged at a residential rate because
those residences are absolutely useless
without that stuff the swimming pool I
liken that to the common areas we have
in nashille where we have a community
swimming pool you can't make any money
at it you can't rent it but you can swim
in it and that is definitely a
commercial
property so I'm not so sure that these
common areas with swimming pools and
club houses and everything are not
commercial property because those of us
who live in residential areas do have to
pay in our taxes a commercial rate for
those very same things and in fact they
are part of what makes people attracted
to the it's a competition kind of thing
so I I I would think that that should be
a commercial rate but would you agree
definitely without any question that
things that make
the residences even function how could
that possibly be
commercial I I would agree I think the
uh the Water the sewer the septic
systems I think all of those things
certainly are residential um in my
opinion when you start talking about
things like clubhouses or pools um then
I think it's a case by case in other
words there are those associations that
use their Clubhouse for commercial
purposes there are those associations
that make their pools uh open in some
way shape or form to the public but
there are those associations that do not
um and at some associations the pool
that they have in the backyard is not
much difference uh from a use
perspective than a pool that anybody
might have in their backyard of a single
family home meaning that it's used
simply by the people who live there as
their residents okay I'm ready
now the issue here
is who owns the
title to those things because electric
bill is just one of those little things
that we pay we pay taxes we pay
insurance we
pay maintenance
cost if the water
system is managed and and if you look at
the uh uh it's man I believe it's going
to be managed by the Association which
is a corporate
entity they're the ones who have to
responsible for the
insurance maybe even taxes for it but I
know I had this conversation once with
my selectman when he was talking about
uh leech fields and I said um show me
where I'm being assessed for my leech
field I don't see that so maybe that's
not the right answer but all at the end
of the day what the issue if I
understand the department of energy
correctly is who owns
title who owns it who has to pay the
taxes for
it that if we were to pass this
legislation we're now giving tax
exemption to entities simply because
they're in the they're servicing a
residential which I think is going to be
problematic when it comes comes to taxes
it comes to uh insurance
payments who who's
liable who's responsible if you know and
when it comes to a happy
homeowner we are right we own that
septic system we own that pump we have
to repair we have to we have all those
responsibilities if I understand
correctly what's going on here is is
that the association technically is the
owner not the
residents and the association is
incorporated for other purposes it's
Incorporated such
as to who's going to pay the taxes who's
going to pay on on taxes on time who's
going to have the Insurance
liability and so therefore the the
question the the the department of
energy is saying is if we were to pass
this legislation you a you open up the
can of worms so what other things could
people want to cost shift on but more
importantly it's a corporation that owns
it not the homeowners if the homeowners
want to have pick a
homeowner and have them own that water
plant that water if they want to have
someone else be the ones responsible for
insuring
it then then yeah you can get the lower
cost and have it to on their meter but
if the meter is being paid by somebody
else then it has a whole new set of
liabilities would you
believe uh yes but uh and thank you uh
for raising the issue um to answer the
question uh at Condominiums uh that
common area to the extent that the pool
is located there or the septic is
located there the common area that isn't
the units from a legal perspective at a
condominium um is understood to be owned
by um each of the unit owner each of the
unit owners um in their percentage of
undivided interest and of the
association it right and so if you have
an association if you didn't have an
association if each one of those people
had in their
deeds it would written in their deeds
that they have their one whatever
portion then
theoretically you know they that that
your utility bill has got but at the end
of the day that electric bill has got to
go to a resident not to an
association that's they don't make the
department have to go over and make and
check and see who's really doing water
that's not what they're asking for
they're asking for who is the owner
if it's a residence then it should be
the resident name on that electric bill
not the
association so I certainly have no
dominion over the department and uh we
are not the sponsors of of the bill so I
can't explain it in the way uh
necessarily that they would um but as an
association um that is uh focused on
Community Association living uh and as
an attorney practicing in this area uh I
would just say that it is uh in the deed
to each of the units what their
percentage of interest is um and then
for tax purposes um associations don't
get a bill to you know quote unquote the
association uh for purposes of taxes the
municipalities look at the property as a
whole to the extent that there's tax
value on the common areas or relative to
the common areas that's incorporated
into the tax bills that each of the
units get um so there is no one paying
taxes other than those units um when it
comes to the rest of the bills the
associations uh that exist even if they
exist as a corporation and they don't
all have to um you're not required to be
a corporation uh that's just one of the
options for those that that choose the
corporate form um you don't necessarily
have a business running you don't have
profit you don't have an income stream
if you're typical residential only
condominium and so uh the money that's
in that pool is nothing more than what
the unit owners are paying as their fee
so it it's just sort of a a collective
it's not an issue of use or business um
but it is all their money um I will say
just to sort of add some more depth to
the discussion that uh I do practice law
in other states uh Beyond New Hampshire
and there uh depending on the state you
sometimes never see a condominium in a
corporate form um there are states where
um almost everyone is for example a
trust uh trust is very common there are
also other sort of legal formations uh
that depending on the state again you
may not find corporations involved at
all I think in New Hampshire it it may
be uh and I'm not sure about this I
wasn't practicing at the time but I
think when Condominiums first got
popular in New Hampshire it may have
just been that the question needed to be
answered you know what are these legal
entities going to be um and you know the
the laws for corporate form uh already
existed and it was easy to say okay just
let them do that paperwork and and
register with the state my final
question and I and I want everyone to
know I was just putting that this is out
as a cond I'm not Shing I'm I own this
or where I am I'm just trying to think
all of this through so the question is
is any other state like Massachusetts do
you do they have the same they have the
similar law uh Massachusetts for example
um they're all trust virtually but I'm
saying in Massachusetts is it uh is the
trust paying the residential rate or the
commercial rate oh my apologies I I have
not looked at the issue in that state so
I don't know the answer I would really
appreciate you if you could do a little
look around from our states around us
sure that'd be great okay representative
grassy has a question yeah I just have a
really quick question and I was looking
at fairness when we were talking about
some of the utilities that on a site do
municipalities pay a separate rate
completely different from a residential
and Commercial rate do you have any idea
or does anybody from the Department any
of the department 7 what municipali you
can ask him offline over that guy over
there I'll ask him offline then that
that's outside of my SCH by thank you
okay any other
questions excuse me representative mcer
have a question well just a comment I I
don't
see just because it's a corporation that
is necessarily a commercial Corporation
it can be a non-commercial corporation
uh we still make nonprofits pay the
commercial
rate because they only have the utility
it only has two rates residential and
Commercial and that's what we we're
dealing with okay thank you very much
thank you all right I have no more cards
I will close the public hearing and yes
I want to sure we do do everything by
subcommittee here so there will be a
subcommittee on this bill and and we
will be discussing it further before
take action having said that I will
close the public
hearing
okay
yeah
okay you ready okay we're going to open
up public
hearing
1306 and here from the prime sponsor
representative
n we're a little stirred up here because
of the heat oh I'm stirred up as well
good afternoon members of the committee
Mr chairman um I've been a
representative I'm on my 14th here now
and as long as I've been here I have
heard had constituents that live in
Condominiums call me with issues
I mean all of us every year there's
there's issues with the Condominiums and
they just seem to get nowhere
constituents with their condo boards and
they're they have no other recourse than
to reach out to the at to the state
level asking for help which is why I'm
here I have two constituents with me
from my town that um will be explaining
the whole situation to you because they
could do it a lot better than I can um
so with that I would I would like to
pass over the mic to my constituents if
that's all right with you absolutely
come on up ladies come on
up I assume you're pilling out you're
filling out your PIN card you that you
girls were here this morning or we
wereing so now you know what's going to
happen
right
okay
so there's two two ping cards there yep
tag
team oh for the next
one yeah we'll take them
all okay that's right let's let's keep
going okay pull team ahead we don't want
to get behind because it's SN one out
there okay um so my name is Ashley
tenhave
um I live in marac New Hampshire
um so this first one is what
1306 okay um
so we've had a lot of situations right
now where our condu association the
board management company um an narts
buun are not spending wisely um and not
spending within the budget um and due to
this we have been informed that we could
be looking at a fairly large
assessment um
for improvements um such as Community
lighting um putting arities around the
neighborhood due to some construction
across the street um that was not dealt
with with the town um and other areas um
we are currently in stage four of Paving
this coming up um and we have many we
have 90
something units basically um and all of
them need new bulkheads new sighting new
roofs um we went through 10 years with a
management company that did zero
maintenance and zero Capital
Improvements on the project um so we are
very far behind um on a lot of issues
and we don't have the capital funds to
be able to manage all of this um as such
we I was a board member for four years
um when this management company we have
right now came on um and we had worked
through a five-year plan to try and get
through as many of the projects as we
could within the budget that we have um
but now that a new board has come on um
spending is not being done within that
plan and we are coming up to time for a
new fiveyear plan and money is just
being thrown to things that are not
important um and anytime any of us speak
up regarding where money is spent and
things like that we keep getting
threatened with a large assessment from
our management company um and thus
trickling down to our board really our
management company runs the show at our
place um the board doesn't have as much
of a voice as we would hope um that they
would against the management company and
the spending um but really we're looking
at quite a lot of money out of our
pocket um our town taxes just went up
our um condo fees just had a second
significant increase and it's still not
enough money for all these projects and
we are basically being
um charged out of our homes at this
point if a if a large assessment goes
through for these due to um
inappropriate spending
elsewhere
um so we would like to have it so that
there is a cap to what a special
assessment can be PR up by the board and
by management without the approval of
the homeowners we have a lot of elderly
people that live in our neighborhood we
have a lot of really young couples um
and it's just right now the board
honestly thinks that they have our
pockets to just pull money out of as
they need to um and we'll just like I
said throw money at just whatever they
want and it's really
sad do you have anything to
add
um so my name is Katie porier I live in
uh marac New Hampshire um I'm in support
of this because it will help the
homeowners have more say to it it
then um just like a rogue board or a
management company that feels empowered
to
um push the board or stack the board in
their favor to have you know these um
maintenance
um things um addressed such as you know
say I know you brought up like the pool
earlier um you know what if a
pool had a crack in it right in ground
pool one pool for whole association
right has a crack in it you could
essentially just fix that one crack and
not have to regrout the whole
thing but management then will say or
the board will say oh no we're going to
do the whole thing all over well you
know there's reason reasons of why the
majority of homeowners should have a say
because it may not be needed you know um
and again irresponsible spending or
being pushed you know to do one thing or
another and not getting the homeowners
input because they're not
informed so it just it would be helpful
for more voices to be
heard okay have questions from the
committee representative Herbert who's
the management
company we don't want to
know I'd really rather not because we've
been kind of threatened with defamation
lawsuits from them as well if we go too
far that can be a side
not okay represent
Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you for
coming and giving us your testimony
I just want to understand the uh the
Dynamics here I I don't have a lot of
experience with condos
associations um so the the idea of a
special assessment uh how often and and
uh what types of things could they be
issued for and if I understand you're
saying the special assessment has to
have it can't exceed 5% of the budgeted
amount of uh
expenses unless approval I guess that
would be in a for in the form of a vote
approval of the unit Owners Association
could you just explain special
assessment and then how would how would
approval if it's over 5% how would the
approval process work
so um so a special assessment is an
extra amount of money on top of our
regular condo fees um it can be assessed
at any point in time that the board
feels that they don't have the budgeted
money to be able to take care of issu as
they come up um so another Association
that we have friends that live at um
they need roofing and sighing they just
finished their Paving project and it has
been found that within their budget they
do not have the money to replace all the
roofing and all the sighting in the
entire complex they have mold behind
their walls they have few other issues
and um they have the same management
company that we do and that
um that amount of Mone it's going to be
over a million dollars to replace all of
that and that million dollars they're
taking out what they do have in their
Capital Improvement project and then
whatever is left over is being assessed
to the homeowners over a two-year period
of time so they are looking at almost
$5,000 um per every six months um to be
paid to the association on top of their
condo
fees um and then yes we would like to
have this be by a vote of the
association um by ballot with um with
every homeowner being able to have a a
say in this um like they would with
other votes being done um such as like
board member votes and things like
that okay repr
repr uh thank you Mr chairman uh I think
it was Ashley that mentioned uh that
routine maintenance had not been done
do you recall for how many years or how
long it had it was at least 10 years at
least 10 years
uh thank you that makes some interesting
information represent
grassy yes thank you uh could do you
know if your management company has paid
a set fee for managing the condo
association or are they paid on a as a
percentage of the overall budget they
are set a set fee fee so there's a
what's called a door fee so they are
paid a certain amount of money per door
in the association so per per household
um and I believe it's close to
$38,000 that we're paying them
yearly um and then um for many
associations luckily ours doesn't have
this but for many associations um
anytime that there is a capital
Improvement project the um manag
companies are also charging a percentage
of that Capital Improvement project for
them to quote unquote manage the
contractors and get the bids for
it did you in your budget did you have
money allocated for Capital Improvements
there is a a reserve account which is
allocated towards Capital Improvement
projects um right now it's running
really low gotcha okay represent
bur thanks for taking my question um
it's a two-part question so there is no
limit on the assessment that these comp
nowhere there is no limit um unless
there's something written in specific
bylaws um but ours and I know I have
friends that live at four other
communities and not one of their bylaws
has a limit on what a special assessment
could be to their homeowners so and
second part of it there must be some
Avenue to go for Bad actors like you
don't see any other than than to go to a
lawyer at this point so we have
contacted lawyers um and we'll speak
upon this later with one of the other
bills that's coming up um you can try
and contact a lawyer there are no
lawyers that actually work with condo
law that are not
already um associated with
associations um so you can try and get a
lawyer it is we were looking at $10,000
for a retainer for a lawyer that does
not know no condo law um to then bring
us in front of a judge that also does
not know condo law um and we would then
run also the risk of having to pay the
association's legal fees if we were not
to win this is there a lawyer in the
house on the wrong
side
two okay
so yes representative M thank you Mr
chairman thanks for coming I'm Tim M you
on one of your reps from marac as well
um stupid question maybe doesn't the
management firm work for the association
and if so can't you fire them or
threaten to fire them get a different
one renegotiate anything so the board
can fire the management company with a
30-day notice um but right now our
current board is very much in favor of
our management company um which we are
we have found is happening with other
associations with the same management
company they basically stack the board
um they get get the votes they get the
proxies they get everything that they
need to hold on to the board members
that vote in their favor and then they
force the other board members out um
that don't um they make it very
difficult to be on the board if you
don't agree with them uh they make it
very difficult to live in your
Association if you do not agree with
them um based on different things that
are said to other homeowners it makes it
very hard to live there which is why I
actually came off the board um it is not
a Pleasant situation when you don't
agree with your management company um it
does take a 23d vote of the entire
Association to remove any contractor on
the association and to get that
two-thirds vote especially with the um
number of houses that are flipping to
new owners um and just the fact that
people just don't want to get involved
um or they're being they call the
management company and they're being
told that they were getting
misinformation from their you know their
neighbor um it's always misinformation
misrepresentation of the you know Board
of the association and it's it's really
difficult to get any sort of
movement
okay thank you very much thank you very
much thank
you uh so I have uh four cards here and
uh in opposition we'll start with uh
Richard Scott sweat
because oh okay that's 157 okay sorry
all right so uh all right so all three
from Cai so which one who wants to be
the first one who wants
it okay Gary and you're GNA keep it to
two minutes
right
thank you uh again for the record Gary
didario here on behalf of the Community
Association institutes legislative
action committee for New Hampshire um I
feel like I'm kind of the spoiler today
because I think I'm about to do this for
the third time um but the statute as it
exists already regulates special
assessments and that was done fairly
recently by the New Hampshire legis
um it wasn't even the big
2016 Amendment it was one of the
subsequent amendments between then and
now um but special assessments are
presently regulated in section 40c of
the statute so we have an amendment here
to change section
52 uh but at section 40c what it says uh
existing law about special assessments
is that they must go through exactly the
same process as the budget
itself so that tells us several things
it tells us the community is going to be
notified it tells us that there's going
to be a meeting and it tells us that
two-thirds of the community can reject
it the same way twoth thirds of the
community can reject the budget um and
so really all the mechanisms are in
place here I believe that if you had a
truly Rogue board that for whatever
reason was operating very irresponsibly
want to spend all kinds of money that
the association doesn't have if the
situation were very bad if it was what I
just described then two-thirds of the
community could come to the special
assessment meeting and say no thank you
we don't want that special assessment
and then it simply doesn't happen um
that's the law as it stands
today um speaking now more generally
about the the bill itself I I think the
problem with with it and believe me it's
not that I I like the idea of people
getting hit with special assessments I
don't I will tell you that in my
practice when I counsel clients I always
counsel them to do anything but a
special assessment if there's any way
you can avoid it you should avoid it a
special assessment is a last resort uh
frankly the mortgage questioner that
lenders use now includes questions about
special assessments and I warn my
clients of that that if you have special
assessments people are going to be
answering those questions on mortgage
questionnaires and what you're doing is
you're actually hurting the
marketability of your units because when
lenders get the questionnaire back and
say oh you do have special assessments
you had a special assessment last year
those are points against the association
and points against that loan application
so special assessments are bad in
general and they are to be avoided that
is the advice that we give cons
consistently but if a special assessment
were needed then by definition we're
talking about something that isn't
included in this year's budget and so by
definition we're talking about something
that apparently we were not expecting
and if something unexpected happens and
it needs to be fixed or repaired or
replaced at an association as it is for
any of us wherever we may live um the
universe doesn't care about what the
cost is it doesn't care about whether
that cost is a specific percentage of
what our household budget might be the
cost just is what it is um what I mean
by that is that in a storm like we have
now or a or a you know wind driven
rainstorm if it's the case that a
section of the roof blows off and it
turns out that the building needs a new
roof again the universe doesn't care the
contractors don't care the people who
make roof shingles nobody cares what
percentage that is of your budget the
issue is it costs what it cost and
unfortunately when you need a new roof
you have to put one on um you know you
just don't have a way around that uh for
the board should you fail to properly
care for the property you're breaching
the fiduciary duty that again the the
statute as it stands today imposes on
the board members and if you're
breaching your fiduciary duty then every
other unit owner at that Association
could potentially bring suit against you
for that and as a board member that's a
sort of a real catch22 if you're going
to have unit owners particularly the
ones maybe who live under the roof leak
sue you and say we need a new roof the
board's not getting a new roof they're
in breach of their fiduciary duty and
then the board is going to sit in a
courtroom and say well we want to
replace the roof we just can't get the
vote that we need under the
statute the fact that that that
situation could arise to me sort of
tells us all that that generally
speaking that's probably not what we
want to be doing in the law if we put
people who serve in these board
positions in those types of predicaments
what we're going to see over time is
that people just aren't willing to do it
they don't want to serve on their board
anymore um and then just lastly and
really quickly speaking of the board and
Property Management uh the comment was
made and and I agree and it's just
simple reality the property manager is
hired by the board and they can be fired
by the board um and so the control
mechanism is there that if for some
reason the property management company
is the problem um there is a way to get
rid of them if the board itself is the
problem there's a mechanism there as
well uh as I think we all know because
again these portions of the statute uh
exist as present day regulation and
they've been modified fairly recently um
boards are constantly up for election at
condominium associations and so if you
had a rogue board that was really that
bad um that was in the pocket so to
speak of the property management company
and they were doing all the wrong things
for all the wrong reasons um then the
next annual meeting is an opportunity
for the entire Community to vote against
them as a board so you can fire your
your property manager you can fire your
board outside of the election process
there again is an existing provision in
the Condominium Act as it stands today
for the removal of board members and so
let's say you find yourself between
annual meetings and between elections
but you've got board members that are so
bad uh that the community can't live
with them then the community can act
under the removal Provisions that
already exist in the statute and remove
those board members even if you're
between elections so again I I I like
the the idea of people not being
subjected to expenses that you know they
find difficult to pay uh but the reality
of the situation is that boards have to
be able to take care of the property and
when things happen especially the types
of things that would warrant a special
assessment um the board unfortunately
doesn't have control over the cost
they're just dealing with whatever the
situation is and they're trying to fix
it and if the situation is that bad the
provisions exist for at the end of the
day the community to speak and oust
whoever they need to oust if that's
what's going on at the association so um
just not sure that that this particular
piece of legislation is necessary um if
it is necessary it probably um should
come somewhere else in the statute
because like I said potentially now you
could have a conflict between different
sections of the statute if you create a
limitation in one um that that doesn't
match with what you're doing for a
process and
another great well um what's the
difference between a special assessment
and a capital
Improvement uh so Capital Improvement is
just when you're spending money sort of
outside the normal routine so it would
be a capital Improvement if you were
replacing the roof uh of the building or
replacing the siding for the building um
the difference being that normally if if
things are are going well Community
plans for a capital expenditure so if
you know your siding is uh
$300,000 and you know that your siding
is good for 30 years at your condominium
um then the math tells you that you put
away about $110,000 a month for your
next $300,000 Reserve siding project
exactly um special assessment would be
that again I'll go with my example
because it's easy and clear special
assessment would be uh let's say for
some reason you're at the midpoint
you're 15 years into your siding you
don't expect to be replacing it yet but
a storm blows it off the building or or
for some reason it has started to rot
and it's falling off the building and
now you find yourself doing your siding
project years early then even if you
were engaged in proper financial
planning um you may not have enough to
do that siding job when you need to do
it and so then Especial assessment
happens where um the community just has
to raise money to meet their present day
needs okay well sounds like uh Capital
Improvement is the same thing it's just
that it wasn't planned on okay that this
is not an expense and it wasn't planned
you didn't have a budget enough money
for the capital Improvement
um they got it
great representative you thank you Mr
chairman Mr diio Dar Dario is that right
thanks um thanks for your expertise on
on these various laws um so maybe you
could review with us a little bit than
your interpretation on the
2/3 rule because what I heard you say if
I understood correctly is that 2/3 can
show up and 2third can reject it which
would almost imply that you need 100% of
those who show up to reject it so you
need both 2third for a quorum and then
everybody all of those two two thirds
have to actually vote to accept or
reject I understanding you correctly or
but potentially I mean if if only
two-thirds of the community come to the
meeting um then yes to meet the
two-thirds voting standard you would
need everybody who's there to vote um
you know along the same controvery over
the years was the fact that that you you
need twoth thirds to overturn the board
right you know because you're voting on
the board's budget you need two at the
end of the day it was it was a very high
threat threshold and and 2third to for
any any action to be
taken oh now I remember what the
question I want to ask you guys can't
bond right you can't go you can't float
money or you can't like your if the
capital Improvement is so huge because
you would have to have every lot every
owner condo owner sign on to the to the
the mortgage note I mean can you borrow
money they can um in fact in recent
years because there are so many
associations I mean let's face it
unfortunately and and some of us may be
guilty of this at our own households
whatever type of residence we we may
live in um human nature is such that
it's probably the minority of folks um
that actually plan so properly that when
the roof needs to be replaced the
money's sitting there when the siding
needs to be replaced the money's sitting
there you know generally speaking
something gets in the way there's not a
lot of uh perfect financial planning
that that goes on in general um in
recent years because so many
Condominiums are of that age now that
these major components need to be
changed over if the if the building of
Condominiums if the Heyday was in the
80s um you know then then they're 40
years old now they need all of these
things um banks in recent years have
realized that there are so many
condominiums in that position that
there's a market for a so-called
condominium loan oh that's good and they
have created needed uh products
specifically for that segment of the
market and what they do in the case of a
condominium to deal with the fact that
you know the common areas are owned by
everybody and this is kind of a messy
situation how do we as the bank protect
ourselves um what they've established
are that standard loan documents for
condominium Loan Today use as
collateralization for the loan the
income stream of the assessments that
the assoc assciation is entitled to
collect from the owners and so if a
Condominium Association defaults on a
bank loan at least one that's been done
with standard docs in recent years um
the bank can step in and start
intercepting that Revenue stream of the
of the assessments that are being paid
by the unit owners into the association
so as with any of us it's not without
risk um you know if you don't pay the
bank you get foreclosed on um that sort
of thing
uh but the product does exist uh and
there are many associations that take
advantage of it and um I I can say in in
my practice uh I have not yet seen an
association that has uh defaulted on a
bank loan typically but you have seen
some taking this loans out oh yes
absolutely um it's getting to be quite
common which is why banks have sort of
structured it as its own product they
have their own um closing documents for
that type of loan um I haven't seen any
associations fall into trouble because
generally speaking they do the math at
the outset and they just always make
sure that they can pay the loan and the
most common way that I see them doing it
is they add the loan payment as a line
item in their budget um so it won't be a
special assessment it'll be part of the
line item of the budget correct okay
represented
Gibbs thank you um I just wanted to
clarify something from personal
experience which is that um condo
associations can uh borrow uh and do
borrow for unexpected uh Capital
needs uh but then the owners have to
approve either a special assessment and
therefore no need to borrow or um uh
collections over a period of time so
that when the loan comes due there will
be enough money there to pay the loan
off
got it just what I
heard okay representing M you thank you
Mr chairman just one more question then
if if I understand you correctly the uh
that
2third
majority could be changed that threshold
could be changed in the condo document
by a two-third majority right so you
could no it's statutory no I I I know
but you couldn't you couldn't say
notwithstanding that you you could was
that was why we get bills every year
about this issue right what so it's
government by minority the onethird can
tell the rest what to do simply well
it's it's simply by not showing up sorry
I'll wait go ahead um so it's it's
governed by the board in the first
instance in other words the the
community elects the board right uh it's
the board's job to sort of figure out
the finances manage the property see
what projects need to happen um if the
board imposes a special assessment um
then it takes two-thirds of the
community to overrule uh what the board
is is doing so the solution is get on
the board and then just get your friends
on the board or whatever
and running theory is that that those
are elected positions and if people
don't like what the board is doing then
then throw them off vote them offe them
off and just to address the the first um
part of the question uh in the section
of the statute that talks about the two3
voting standards for different things
including amendments and so on um the
statute say already says um except if
the condominium documents require a
larger percentage um so they don't go
smaller but they do allow communities
the opportunity to require more buyin
before a major change
happens further question how how would
you or your group feel about lowering
the threshold to
35ths 60% instead of
66.66%
I mean I I guess the problem is the the
two-thirds got set um just a few years
ago really and there was a lot of debate
about it as I recall um at that time and
part of what happened was we saw like a
line of of board members they couldn't
be contained in the room some of them
had to be called in from outside to
speak and people were basically saying
if you're going to saddle me with the
fiduciary duty to take care of the
property properly and then you're going
to tell me that the community who by the
way no one ever wants to pay more bills
I mean none of us do regardless of of
what it is or or why it is but what the
board members are saying is if you're
going to saddle us with a fiduciary duty
to care for the property properly then
you're going to tell us that if the wind
blows off the siding or the siding rot
and we say we're doing a siding project
the community comes out and says no
we're not not now we can't even do the
job that we've been elected to do and
that we have a fiduciary obligation to
do and what we heard was board member
after board member sat here and said if
you pass this I'm going to resign I'm
never going to serve on the board again
so at at some point it gets difficult to
find people to fill these volunteer
positions to be in charge of the
condominium because it's a bit of a
thankless
job so we uh I can have my researcher
show you the history that we revisit
this that statute multiple times over
the years so thank you very much thank
you okay uh I I assume you're Paul
because you've been sitting there all
the time and all morning and there's no
other Pam the way you wrote your name
here sorry about that I assume you're
Paul and I'll let you pronounce your
last name it's a nice Polish boy Paul
okak and I'm with the New Hampshire Lac
for Cai
great
I please don't say anything we haven't
heard already just no I'm going to frame
it differently because you know I see
things from a different perspective I I
personally am involved with an
association in miramac that's about 21
or 22 years old and here's how it's done
correctly from the day that the
association was built they had a reserve
study done now I'm sure you're familiar
with that it's it's a engineering
actuary that gives it the life expense
expectancy of roof Paving siding then
the cost to how much you have to save uh
to achieve those goals at the time that
it's
replaced they set their fees
appropriately back when they were first
built I won't say high I won't say low
they set their fees appropriately to
save for those issues that are going to
come up down the road they're now in the
process of a
three-year roof replacement project for
about 1.8 million they're writing a
check because they followed the reserve
study the boards the fiduciaries were
proactive in setting the fees to pay for
those and now they can write checks and
not have assessments or increase fees or
bank loans they've structured this out
through the years to pay for these items
and the board is very good and yes
elections come up and sometimes board
members change and the community members
change the board members and as far as
management goes management does not have
a vote on the budget the budget is set
by the board management can have its
input maybe where some line items need
to change but the board sets the budget
as the governing board and as the
fiduciaries then from there it goes to
the unit owners for the vote and I can
tell you doing this for almost 40 years
I've never seen an association reject a
vote or a budget because back to uh
Gary's
point legislator and in its wisdom put
board members as fiduciaries because you
can take
356b run it down to two things the
boards are infrastructurally and
financially responsible for the
infrastructure of that Association that
is it you can we can have all the laws
we want but the board member the buck
stops with them and if the board's over
the years because I happen to be on the
management side if we take over an
association that has not been managed
well for years and capital projects were
not planned for or budgeted they have to
get done somehow and shame on those
boards in the past that did not plan for
that on the good example that I showed
you and many associations and boards and
community members are saddled with a
deficit because the the rate of
deterioration and the rate of inflation
far exceed that of which boards are
raising the fees to be able to take care
of those elements so as that Gap expands
at some point there has to be some type
of either bank loan uh assessment or
increase fees to close that Gap and get
the capital projects completed because
what happens with that is if the capital
projects are not completed and things
aren't done the value of the property
declines that hurts everybody so it's
it's a real it's it's a real Balancing
Act and to saddle with just 5% can harm
an association because those things need
to be done and there is and there are
mechanisms in place to make sure that
those costs can be contained we have
worked with associations that have done
dozens of bank loans never one defaulted
and we take those bank loans in that
budget to the owners for approval and
they were always passed because the
owners realize that there's going to be
new this this and it's all outlined and
you you can't get a bank loan for a
project and do another project with that
money the bank loan has to be for the
project that is stated so the mechan
mechanisms are in place and there's a
lot of good in the world that happens
with all of this and I gave you an
example when it's done right and I feel
very bad for associations that have not
been either the board has not done their
duties or the management has not done
their duties and as far as management
taking a fee um managements do take does
does earn a fee if it's in the in the
management agreement and most management
agreements is if the board chooses to
elect to have that management company
oversee the project they could have an
engineering Pro uh company oversee the
project or they could have management or
many boards do it themselves and avoid
the fee so that is an option it's not
mandatory so I want to put a little
oxygen back in the room that perhaps
maybe this process isn't as bad as it it
seems because democracy can and it does
work and I've seen it work for four
decades any
questions seeing none thank you very
much I can't I can't compete with the
lawyers so
maybe but well that's why I insert you
between the two of them thank you thank
you do do you have written
testimony
Paul did did you have written
testimony okay uh Dean obviously thank
you Mr Hunt uh and good afternoon uh
Dean Lennon for Cai so I won't I'm
trying not to repeat anything anyone
said but when the two individuals
testified as to why this bill is
necessary the things I heard them talk
about was spending for Paving siding and
roofs these are things that boards are
charged with maintaining and repairing
and replacing so to hamstering the board
by putting a decision to redo roofs and
what could be more important leaving it
up to a community vote where it can be
rejected simply because people don't
want to pay for it you really put a huge
hurdle uh in in front of the board who's
trying to fulfill their FID fulfill
their fiduciary duty to the condominium
itself and what happens if the community
rejects it and you've got a roof that's
leaking on units and every time there's
a storm you have four or five unit
owners with $1,000 worth of damage in
their unit what are they going to do
they're going to sue your cont minum so
you might have saved the money for this
additional assessment but now you've
been sued and maybe you lose your
insurance or at a minimum your uh
premium is going to go
up just to hit on this point it's
section 40c already strikes a balance by
giving the 23ds the ability to veto a
budget so we've already kind of dealt
with this issue uh ad nauseum in the
past there are a couple of deficiencies
with this bill has written one is it
says the approval of the unit owners we
don't know what percentage that
requires it's proposed to be in section
52 uh which is what the contents of the
public offering statement for a condo
this really should be in 40c if it's
anywhere of course I don't think it
should be anywhere but if it's anywhere
it should be in
40c um and it uses the word improvements
which as I discussed earlier is sort of
a term of art when it comes to
Condominiums an improvement is something
new uh but really it seems to me we're
talking about Capital expenditures for
existing common elements but um in in my
estimation uh this uh this bill is a
tremendous impediment to the ability of
a board to fulfill its fiduciary duties
and for that reason you should reject
it thank you very much thank
you okay I have no more
cards so I'm close the public
hearing and as soon as the clerk's ready
we'll start in on
1357 good afternoon again um I'm
representative Janine ner I'm the
sponsor of this bill and for the same
reasons for the last one I had
constituents approach me and and you you
will fill out a card right yes for both
of them um and if it's all right with
you I would like to have the same two
constituents come up and explain the
bill to you that'd be
great
thank you again for hearing from us um
and this is
is
1357 yep okay um so I'd like to say that
I we are asking for this bill um because
it would cause boards and management to
be more transparent with their
homeowners um again I was on the board
for over four years in our association
and in that time we had had one closed
board meeting um and we closed that
board meeting because of a large rockus
that was that was um cause that we
couldn't even speak because the
homeowners just wouldn't allow us to
talk and that was the only time we'd
ever closed a board meeting to our
association um so right now what is
occurring is um our board is only
opening the the sessions basically for
that one and a quarter um that they are
that they are required to do by the law
um at this time um they talk about
wanting to be transparent
um with the homeowners and wanting the
homeowners to be educated as to what's
going on with the
association and they talk about how you
know just ask questions just just call
management ask the question we shouldn't
have to ask the question if we can sit
there and listen to the board meeting
we're not asking for every single board
meeting to be open for us to speak we're
asking for every Bo for the the monthly
board meetings to be allowed for
homeowners to be able to listen to what
is going on um executive session is
closed to all homeowners as it should be
um as that is most that is all legal
things that are going on but for the
general comings and goings of the
association the homeowners should be
able to hear what is going on and we
should know what is being voted on who
is voting on what if we choose to be
there to listen to this
um uh right now just
from experience that we've had and
experience that many of our friends in
town at other associations have had um
it's come to the feeling that the board
and Management Field that an informed
homeown owner is a pain or a difficulty
um unless they can direct the narrative
that is being sent out to the homeowners
um normally you would have meeting
minutes that you would be able to go
back to to see what was voted on and
comments our association has no meeting
minutes posted since November of 202
two we have asked for them to be posted
um they are not um this is not the first
time this has happened this is actually
the third time that this has happened
where it has been multiple months that
no homeowner knows what has been voted
on what has been discussed at the board
meetings um unless they are actually
able to be there so we are asking for um
this to be more than just once every
quarter that a homeowner is allowed to
come and sit and listen to these board
meetings so that we are aware of what's
going on on our association we're aware
of what decisions are being made by our
board and who's making those decisions
we have the responsibility at the annual
meeting to vote on whether or not we are
keeping the board members that are up
for reelection or if we're going to
choose another member that has decided
another homeowner that has decided to
speak up and decide that they wanted to
join the board but how are we to do that
if we don't know what's being voted on
who's being voted um and all of that and
if we're not actually able to sit there
and know what's going on in our
associations um representative burough
thanks for taking my question just
curious do do you think that it's one
size fits all and that every Association
does need needs to meet monthly I think
it's a good I I I don't think that
everyone probably needs to meet monthly
some of the smaller associations might
be able to manage most of their stuff um
without it um our current bylaws in our
association says that we're supposed to
have a monthly meeting um we have a very
good siiz Association we have 145 units
um and as said previously we have a lot
of Maintenance and a lot of Capital
Improvements and a lot of other things
that are going on that us homeowners
should know is going on and is happening
and as having a large Association it's
nice to be able to sit there and listen
to what is our board doing for us what
are they spending our money on what are
you know what are we what are we voting
for them to continue to represent us
for um so I think you know for for many
especially the larger associations that
do currently hold monthly meetings um I
think it's good for them to continue to
happen but I think that they should be
allowed to have the homeowners be there
to listen to it um again executive
sessions completely separate that that's
all the legal stuff that's all the stuff
that you know is not privy to the
homeowners and that's fine but any of
the normal day-to-day business if a home
owner wants to know what's going on and
wants to be informed we should be able
to sit there and listen again not having
to comment and not having to have an
open homeowner session where we can
speak every time but we should at least
be able to listen um it's just like Town
meetings and legislative meetings and
all of that stuff we should be able to
to listen and to know what's going
on okay questions none thank you very
much thank
you who's making a donation to our
coffee
fund
five five
bucks okay
uh so Richard
twit we appreciate that and the clerk
especially
appreciates especially since he's clerk
for the
day
well I've introduced myself before so
I'll just go straight into our position
on
1357 the condominium Leadership Council
the board of directors of The Vineyards
and the hills at Crockett Farms oppose
the enactment of
1357 we believe that RSA 356
b35 which states that she'll be recorded
simultaneously with the Declaration of
bylaws provided in the self-government
of the condominium buying Association of
all unit owners this amendment mandating
monthly meetings by the state is
contrary to the concept of
self-government a meeting is unnecessary
for the amount in nature of business
that is presented to the association in
the property management company serving
our associations with the existing
statute the association has the option
option to call a monthly meeting if
necessary we go four quarterly meeting
meetings a year board members are
volunteers today finding unit owners to
serve on boards and committees is
difficult to mandate 13 yearly meetings
compared to the present requirement of
four meetings will further exacerbate
the lack of participation in association
Affairs recommendation of the condem
leadership board the vineyard and
Crockett Hills board is not to approve
this legislation thank you for hearing
my
testimony
any questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you okay next is well let's go in
reverse order Dean you go
first thank you uh for the record Dean
Lennon Cai New England what I would
encourage this board not to do is to
legislate based on Rogue boards or the
tiny minority of boards that are doing
the wrong thing as things currently
stand boards are supposed to have open
meetings one at least once per quarter
if they're meeting there must be an open
session and meeting uh minutes must be
taken they're supposed to be produced
within 60 days of the meeting or within
15 days of being
produced the people that introduce this
uh legislation have a terrible board or
based on their
testimony their board does not produce
minutes even though the law requires
them to produce minutes so I don't think
yet another law produce requiring boards
to produce uh meeting minutes and
promptly give it to the owners will
change anything for their board you
can't make you can't micromanage condos
there's a slew of litigation that has
come out over the last eight years that
is micromanage condos and this is yet
another attempt to do so and it is
virtually impossible to find volunteers
to fill these slots when you have a Road
board Rogue board you have the power of
the ballot to remove them you have the
the power of the removal process to
remove them so you don't even have to
wait for the election you can call a
special meeting and remove a rogue board
but please do not legislate based on the
tiny minority of bad boards because most
boards are good they're composed of
people who have ninet to-5 jobs or or
just a day job is what I'm trying to say
not a 9 to-5 job a a day job and then
they pour their heart and soul into
their condo for no money um we don't
need more legislation uh affecting them
and with that I'll close and take any
questions okay so I'm going to ask you
this question because it's going to be
uh with bills coming up are still going
to fall forward so clearly the statute
requires them the minutes supposed to be
printed after 60 days if a board did not
do
that a condo owner should do what to get
those minutes I think you could file a
lawsuit and in the it would be like a be
a breach of fiduciary duty or just a
violation of the condo statute and and
require get a a judge to issue an order
requiring the board to produce minutes
for all of the meetings uh and then to
follow the statute going forward and you
could get your legal fees for that if
you
won
okay questions from the committee uh
representative MCU had his hand up first
and then you can represent
Herbert how do I put this delicately
isn't it a bit
ridiculous to ask members that own
property there to file a lawsuit to get
minutes from a
meeting of folks who essentially are
elected by them and work for them and
potentially have to expend legal fees
and potentially have to pay their
adversaries legal fees I mean what what
are these boards hiding that or they
want to delay release of why can't they
just post the minutes oh I I I couldn't
agree more I think it's absurd and I
would never advise a client not to
produce minutes I think the reason we're
here is because someone wants another
law requiring minutes to be produced
well that law already exists and the
timing is 60 days this one says promptly
so there's a bit of a change there but I
agree with you boards should be
producing minutes they should make them
available nothing should be hidden
nothing follow up for the question Meir
is are there points where 60
days is too long because those minutes
contain something that maybe is
objectionable or they want to take
action of and would you would you
support making it you know 10 working
days or something like that I personally
would support 30 days I think 10 is
difficult um you working days 10 working
days so it's two two business weeks
longer if there's a holiday in there
somewhere I suppose I wouldn't lose
sleep over it but I I I I I speak for my
myself only I think 30 days would be
reasonable because it's you know people
have lives um and they can't always just
go home and and produce this stuff uh
after working their job going to their
condo meeting and maybe they have to
take care of children or uh a parent so
let's not ask too much of our volunteers
uh in these positions could I live with
30 days me personally yes I could so not
withstanding you this is going to lead
on to representative Aly be we you know
we have some other
bills the issue
is not 30 days 60 days 10 days if a
board doesn't issue the
minutes period they don't issue the
minutes and that that there how do you
compel a volunteer
board to you know do their
job and you obviously your response was
well you have you got to go find a
lawyer and sue them okay um and
represent Alby thinks that we can they
can come to a committee and maybe they
can uh the committee will browbeat that
board to get those minutes out of that
out of that board but maybe not so the
Ed resolution is that is the same as
electing those boards that the only
resolution this this is my question for
you is it not the only real resolution
is that now you've got to then find
2third of the condo owners to vote to
have a special meeting and throw the
board out because they won't issue their
minutes well you might not need that
many but I mean I think in all walks of
life there are issues that you confront
where a lawsuit's your only option and
listen I am not a litigator I don't like
to file lawsuits over over silly things
but if you if you go to get your car
fixed and they do a lousy job you can go
back and say listen you screwed up my
car you've got to fix it and maybe they
do and maybe they don't and if they
don't
you don't need a a law on the books to
have we do have one but what I mean we
have the consumer protection act well I
yes but you still have to invoke those
rights don't you have to go to court the
consumer protection act is you can go to
court and you get Triple damages yeah uh
but we actually have an attorney general
whose responsibility would be to take
that call and usually the Attorney
General will then call the the auto
repair well condo owners can go to the
attorney general as well what I'm saying
you know the car was just one example
call anything you get a you go to the
the takeout uh restaurant you get the
wrong order about that the problem is
that all the Attorney General's office
or all the consumer protection act is
really intended to do is to make you
whole get your money back but in this
case these are minutes and the board
doesn't want to print them and print
board does whatever excuse they don't
why they don't do
it how how there's no how how's it
attorney general going to how and force
you know them to produce them I presume
if enough owners cared they could just
elect a new board who will do the right
thing and again we're not talking about
the majority of boards we're not talking
about even a large minority we're
talking about a tiny minority in my
opinion corre got that okay thank you
thank you all right that was Dean great
so I'm going reverse order so Paul
you're in the middle
now so used to have years ago remember Z
maybe it was can there was a there was
an association for condo
owners was it was it wasn't it called
Can Am I am I dreaming this up that was
even before your time are we in a
different building yeah okay go ahead
all right Paul okak
again same
people the the concern with this is
questions question I know you said not
to repeat anything but put different
perspectives is I I can tell you this
that volunteer board members are
declining there are boards supposed to
have five we're lucky if we have three
there's boards that are supposed to have
seven members we're lucky if we have
four um the the pressure on the legisl
legislature and and laws that are coming
in to put pressure on boards and out
with their families or whatnot they're
starting to retract from being
volunteers it's a problem in our
industry to go to monthly board meetings
is is a little daunting because you have
condos out there anywhere from five
units to 498 units in New Hampshire and
to require board member
volunteers uh to attend a monthly
meeting for things that just kind of
normally run and when most condos are
run well uh they put in the contracts
for a landscape and snow and a painting
cycle and a roofing cycle and things
just kind of flow and once boards make
those executive decisions they're
implemented and things go fine uh the
other thing with this is if if you if
you implement or or care to implement 12
meetings a year many management
agreements with their client boards
are they specify because time is the
commodity of the management company uh
they specify how many meetings the
management will attend or how many board
meetings there are so if you have a
management company that has a a a client
that they are to meet with four times a
year and you go to 12 that's going to
adjust the management fee which
ultimately puts the fee burden on to the
unit owners
so back to what everybody says the
processes and the laws are already in
place to do a broad brush approach and
legislate our industry for a Association
or an association or two that may not be
following it uh my suggestion would be
for that assoc or a few unit owners we
have a Trade Organization Community
Association
Institute is that to contact them and
see if there's any attorneys or what
maybe the Trade Organization for our our
industry can do to help that situation
uh so there are other means to maybe
help help folks like this so this is
very daunting to put on to associations
that really don't need
it any
questions representative
Ammon thank you Mr
chair I'm not sure if this is uh an
appropriate question for you no go ahead
U thank you for your testimony uh
there's an existing statute that
requires boards to to take minutes and
release the minutes um that that seems
to be already it's uh 356b
37 um I I won't read all the details but
they're required to take them release
them within a certain time frame and
then keep them available for a number of
years right
um is is that is that section of this
bill redundant with current statute and
then if so are we just talking about
monthly versus quarterly is
that the Crux of it the the minutes are
be to to be distributed and and if I may
regress for a moment on the time frame
of minutes minutes are to be approved at
the next board meeting so if boards meet
every other month mon then they can't be
approved within 30 days uh what minutes
can be done is maybe distributed to the
public as a draft and the board approve
them or a board maybe approve them
through some emails so we can get them
out to out to the the populace but board
minutes are done within 30 days a 10 day
back to Dean's point you have folks we
we can't even get board members to
respond to emails half the time but back
to this is if your question is this this
is going from quarterly to every month
and that's that's that's huge that is
huge and if if minutes are not
distributed then there's an issue a a
micro issue not a macro issue and that
should be addressed on the micro
level okay representative
Herbert
um um I think it would be a fair
statement to say that we need uh we need
to enforce the law
I I I'm I'm a little
um concerned about the fact that um you
have an man you have a professional
management company apparently that's got
a contract you have board members
apparently and then you have nothing's
being done and there the law is being
broken and and apparently the civilians
the homeowners it's up to them to file a
lawsuit in order to get the law enforced
and to me that that's backwards and so I
think the problem I see is that the
state doesn't have the uh uh
infrastructure or the people to enforce
the law and and that disturbs me and uh
if uh because a lot of this stuff is
somebody's being
incompetent there's there's incompetence
here and that is not being
punished and we somebody should go in
take the uh uh um the people that are
not doing their job and are being paid
for it and saying you're out of here I'm
going to put somebody else in here who
does a really good job and but only
somebody like the AG can do that kind of
thing and so uh these folks are out and
left to drrive they don't have the
ability or the money to change anything
you can't get a
734 2/3 vote 34 vote to get anything
done there's only one thing that can
happen that will actually get something
done and you put a cop on the
beat the log's being broken it's not
being
enforced end of story that is correct
but the the the good thing about this is
there are safety nets in place that can
if an enacted can take care of those
situations such as call for a special
meeting um I I I would have difficulty
understand or believing that just a few
members of an association with an
assessment like this or whatever are
just saying we the ones being wrong that
there aren't more involved I've again
been in this business I've seen boards
overthrown I've seen all kind of
different stories make your hair curl
but the processes were followed and when
the processes are followed it works it
works beautifully so processes are there
it's all in 356b of of board board how
to overthrow a board how to call a
special meeting how to remove a board
member elections the it's the process
look at our well look at the Iowa
caucuses last night I mean that's kind
of how our democracy
works
jez okay I didn't say it was right or
wrong okay but that's the process so do
you know a lawyer that that represents
unit owners have you have you ever met a
laer a lawyer who actually represent
unit owners I I don't know of any uh H
that's the problem we need you know we
no we don't have anybody who does that I
just I've been just Googling it here and
and I find a lot of fine law firms who
are really willing to help the condo
association but nothing nobody wants to
be there for the unit owner I I disagree
with that again I think well you
disagree tell me would you find one for
me so when we have our subcommittee can
you come in with a couple of of lawyers
who would be willing to help these these
folks out just get their minutes I I
think that again our Trade Organization
when they hear that our industry is
being wronged will certainly have
somebody that will step well I got three
of you right here so the three of you
you're going to find some lawyer for me
right somebody either that how about you
make the phone call to that condo and
tell them to just give them their damage
exactly well okay thank you thank you
all right Gary Mr chairman Mr Mr
chairman I one more question for that
witness if he'll take it how about Gary
he's he's no it's for this gentleman all
right come on
back thank you thank you for taking the
question I think you mentioned you were
from marac would you actually because
you probably know some of the players
involved here I'm guessing and I don't
actually aside from the constituents
behind you and a fellow representative
would you make that phone call if you
happen to know him just because it would
probably save a lot of people a lot of
time and there's three or four of you
here who have an interest in this and
four of you at least that can stop
showing up and get these folks what they
need I'm not an attorney but I play one
on TV so right um I can't come from a
legal perspective I can come from a
management company perspective we'll get
Gary up here I'll have to I'll have to
buy Gary lunch and see what we can do or
Dean so there we go thank you come on
Gary
I mean all these years you don't know a
single lawyer who has ever pursued a
case so uh I was going to start there
actually um I apologize because I'm
horrible with names in general and I'm
not coming up with any off the top of my
head as I sit here but I can guarantee
you that these people exist they're
maybe not as easy to find as those of us
who do this sort of thing publicly for
associations but they exist the proof of
that is that when I go to court they're
whoever's on the other side oh um all
you have to do is look at some previous
cases and you know who the attorney
represented yes if if I was at my office
give a couple of these then yes if I was
at my office looking at papers um I can
tell you that there are those attorneys
who will represent unit owners because
they show up in court and they're on the
other side I've dealt with them so I
know that all I'm asking from you is
when we have the subcommittee you give
me three New Hampshire lawyers and and
you'll make my day okay I will make a
note because that's going to solve all
these bills if we just
had lawyers who would represent people
okay uh fair enough um also I think what
what might help on these bills is the
fact that I previously referred to
myself as the spoiler because I keep
telling you what already exists um but
spoiler probably has a negative
connotation and and maybe it's good news
um maybe I should be telling you that
the good news is that because of the
regulations and law that exist you don't
necessarily need more um I won't beat a
dead horse you've already heard that the
law already requires both meeting
minutes and
financials um but what I would like to
do is draw your attention just to to
where it is briefly it's at 37e 37- e of
356b which is the the Condominium
Act and um again just so everybody's on
the same page it it doesn't say at
present 30 days or 60 days it says
within 15 days of a unit owner's request
at present um that's what it says the 60
days comes from the fact that the board
has that long on the outer end to
approve meeting minutes um but what the
law already says is the 60 days um from
the time of the meeting or 15 days from
the time of unit owner requests them um
so we actually already not only have
this covered by existing law but it's
covered in more specific detail uh the
bill that we're looking at says meeting
minutes uh you know be uh produced
promptly and uh as we all know speaking
of attorneys um you know if we had a
couple in the room we could argue about
whether or not today's Tuesday that's
just sort of how it goes so there will
certainly be arguments about what it
means for meeting minutes to be
delivered promptly uh but in 37e you
already have an objective standard that
exists uh with the 15 days and the 60
days so I I would say that um you know
you've got that
covered I also just want to address very
briefly the notion of the Rogue bad
board members that exist and the
community possibly getting rid of those
board members um there's been a lot of
talk of the 2third standard and uh
that's understandable because the 2third
standards applies in a lot of different
areas but with respect to removal of a
board member this is at section
40-b of of the existing statute and it
says that a um member of the board of
directors may be removed with or without
cause if the number of votes cast in
favor of removal exceeds the number of
votes cast in opposition to removal and
in plain English that's just a simple
majority standard so if an association
where the community feels that one or
more board members is Rogue and and
they're bad and they need to be removed
has a me
uh and they seek to remove this board
member the existing law at
40b uh puts forth just a simple majority
standard for that so that is not a a
two-thirds of the community issue and a
and a rogue board member can be
dismissed um lastly with respect to the
notion of uh associations being required
now to meet on a monthly basis um it
it's a lot you heard that from Paul
who's a property manager who's in the
industry who knows what's involved uh
with these meetings um and I'll only add
to that by giving a a practical
consideration that there are a lot of
associations in New Hampshire that are
what you might call Summer associations
they're up at the lake and it's where
people go for fun in the summer they're
not around right now to have these
meetings conversely New Hampshire has a
number significant number of
condominiums that are what you might
call Winter Condominiums they're up at
the mountains where everybody goes to
ski and those folks are not around up
there in the summer so monthly meetings
I I I would suggest are not suitable for
everyone um someone made a comment
earlier about is this a on siiz fits-all
issue uh probably not I I think what you
should do is leave two associations uh
to determine what meetings they need at
their Association if you have a year
round they might might decide they want
monthly meetings and if so there's
nothing stopping that um but again
you've got your summer places you've got
your winter places so really when it
comes to how many times and when the
board meets I think you really need to
you know rely on the individual boards
at their individual associations to
decide when they need meetings and and
when is a good time to have
them that's all I have happy to answer
questions if there are great just help
me out when we do our committe uh yes I
made a note and then I don't I made a
note my adversaries will be thrilled uh
that Peter Flynn securing why I know
that name Flynn Peter Flyn construction
no no this is a
lawyer I just pulled him up he but like
my Google but I used to have a someone
used to do consumer protection statute
but oh I see oh I'm sorry one last Quick
Point uh to address a question that was
just sort of floating um the reason why
we as attorneys can't necessarily call a
rogue board um and say Hey you calling C
you would be calling as CIA saying
listen you know can you guys find your
way to and I'm sure they'll have lots of
stories to tell you about these two
lovely ladies here and but but then you
say I don't care all I know is the
chairman of the committee really wants
me to urge you to just so yes there are
within the Trade Organization there are
folks uh I believe that might be able to
do that um for those of us that are
attorneys I just want to mention that
the um rules of professional conduct for
attorneys prohibit us from interacting
directly with someone else's client
correct um so that's why I couldn't just
callate but he said he wasn't a lawyer
so right right one of you guys can make
that phone call for yes within the Trade
Organization I believe there are people
appreci um I just wanted for the record
to say that the reason why those of us
that are attorneys can't just call
anybody is because we're not allowed to
call other people's clients thank you
very much thank you oh did we take one
question yes repres Amon has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for your testimony
um I I followed your references to the
15-day requirement to release financials
and the minutes my only question is what
happens if they don't what's the the
recourse um so oh actually thank you for
this question I meant to mention that
and I I failed to do so um one form of
recourse we've talked about is removal
of board members and and like I just
said the standard is not 2third it's a
it's a majority uh when that meeting
happens um another form of recourse
which you've already heard is to go to
court um but to sort of temper that
response I will say that again existing
law in the New Hampshire Condominium Act
this is at uh section 15
Roman numeral 2 states that the
prevailing party recovers their legal
fees and costs and so you know to the
extent that the idea is or that the
general notion is that well unit owners
can't afford the legal process and so
they're shut out and they can't be
required to do that um if you've got
folks that have such a good case that
they're about to be able to demonstrate
that there haven't been proper meetings
that there hasn't been maintenance done
for 10 years that they don't have any
meeting minutes for whatever span of
time that exceeds the statute if folks
are prepared to demonstrate that um even
setting aside that that people do have
the option to represent themselves and I
see plenty of that as well um in court
and and judges are very open to
listening to people speak about their
own issues um but even if they get an
attorney if they demonstrate that sort
of case hey hands down my board is
breaking the law it says they have to do
minutes they're just not doing them then
under section 15 Roman numeral 2 they
will be able to recover uh those legal
fees that's in the statute
now
okay thank you thanks all right moving
right
along what's the next
11:29
yep I didn't I was up there I didn't
I'll be
okay well that's true I didn't hit the
gavel so hurry up come on
up yeah thank you very much sir no
problem all right so really quick
volunteers yes and I was one but oh
sorry Katie porier mayor M New Hampshire
um so volunteers yes that is what you
signed up for that is what everybody
signs up for being a volunteer um one
size fits-all no like they said seasonal
I get it but they also have the
opportunity of meeting by Zoom so they
don't have to necessarily go in but
people could still go and watch and it
could just be a 10-minute meeting hey
this is a followup or this is an update
cool moving
along um
so that fits that um I like the bill I
think the Bill's great
because what you're doing if you're not
allowing a quarterly is you're
restricting your unit owners your
homeowners that want to be educated want
to know what is going on within my
property
investment right I am investing in this
common area so if there's trees being
cut down bu my you know bu my unit I'd
like to know but I wouldn't know for
three months
[Music]
um see so not going to go about the
whole Road board thing but Town meetings
and stuff I don't necessarily go all the
time but I do watch them because again I
want to be
educated
um and something about the car repair
and it you know following up if it's
still out a quarterly I would have to
wait three months or watch what's
happening in my community to get an
update I wouldn't be able just to call
because when I call management they're
like oh I'll have to talk to the board
about that and the board's not meeting
for another three months so I'm in limbo
for three
months so that there's a lot of talk
about meeting minutes wasn't really
wanted to redirect that you know
meetings itself are important as well
well so thank you oh sorry any
questions okay I think we're all set
thanks okay now I'm going to close the
hearing all right represent Aly
1129 and I'm happy to say that I have
nobody in opposition to this
bill don't say anything that changes it
please
well the first thing that I want to do
is to distribute a
small on relevant
Amendment okay which was handed to me by
my co-conspirator who is not in the
legislature
co-conspirator which we received his
testimony emailed
yeah yes we got his
email yeah you can just pass them around
don't worry just keep
going we got a snowstorm out there
and we all want to get home before it
gets
dark you don't know
okay
uh so
this
bill this bill is a lot narrower than
the following bill and I will have my
say about governance at that point but
this is specifically about
proxies from a gentleman who has a lot
to say about governance and he it's up
to you whether he includes it there or
he stays and he includes it later um but
on his
condominium has decided that since when
we adjusted the law to
say that
um a undirected proxy cannot be uh cast
by a person holding more than 10% of the
votes we neglected to ad to Define
proxy and directed proxy and undirected
proxy so they have decided that there is
only one kind of proxy it is a directed
Pro undirected proxy in which case um a
large part of his condominium uh is
people who live out of state and are are
here for weekends and things
occasionally and um the board sends them
the proxies the
directed uh undirected proxies that say
that the board has the right to vote
your proxy however it
wants and um he's been in quite a long
fight uh about this so I'm going to
leave him to tell that Tale But what
this bill does is it defines
proxy I checked in on the internet in
legal sections for that uh it defines a
directed
proxy it defines an undirected
proxy and then it says that um the the
votes pertaining to a unit uh if in
person have to be at a properly noticed
meeting of the unit Owners Association
which is not always quite the case uh or
pursuant to to a directed or undirected
proxy and that the unit owner has the
choice of which
one um I do this quite easily with my
homeowners association I tell them all
the things we're going to vote
on and um they can decide whether
they're directing the results on each of
them
uh then
um the
other part of this is
that it takes and and this part I is
also something I changed in the
amendment when I realized what we' done
um it creates
um a new paragraph D that they've
removed from paragraph B um that says
that it's not applying to time sharing
interests the time sharing Condominiums
if nobody has mentioned that yet uh are
um are determined not to be involved in
condo law and quite rightly because they
usually have got 52 owners for each
unit and it would be a little difficult
and they run it like a
hotel so um that's the bill itself the
amendment um there is in in
red uh put in under the voting process
uh a new subsection that says that the
complete text of all voting articles
must be included in the properly noticed
meeting agenda voting on Amendment
articles amended during a meeting must
be deferred until the next properly
noticed meeting so that um and proper
notice must be delivered to all
condominium owners um
that that is intended to avoid them
amending a bill that says we are going
to um to
appropriate uh
$200 to repairing the roofs to we are
going to appropriate
$2,500
to to uh repairing the roofs without the
membership knowing
and it should result in things like the
the board finding out how much this is
actually going to cost and if they don't
find it out right then like we have had
to do we're going to have to wait until
until the next meeting and they could
call a special meeting ear quickly if
they needed
to so that that's the bill and the amend
Amendment
which on I guess I amended a little bit
to fit it in there but um is mostly
written by John Cummings who I hope you
will ask next but there is another thing
oh no this one isn't this one the other
one's for the next
bill but thank you okay so uh given
my uneducated
mine uh I would consider uh a proxy a
piece of paper Okay first you have the
agenda and you have the language for all
the different motions
right okay and then you'll have a
separate piece of paper that we're going
to call a
proxy and on that proxy would be each a
number related to the
amendment that if at some point in time
someone says oh you made a mistake in
the amendment or anything's not right
with with the amendment regardless of
what anybody voted on the amendment
cannot be taken up because it's going to
be a needs to be
amended and lastly directed
versus
undirected in my mind is very important
because directed means when I take that
proxy and there's going to be yes
no you could say
abstain
okay right yes no or abstain or abstain
could be if you just left that line on a
blank could still be it would default to
abstain but that you can't take up any
new
items you cannot expect someone at the
meeting to say well that person really
does mean something differently because
the proxy is what that person signed and
owns and only that can can be voted on
the meeting if we're
there then we're good yeah okay we're
good the biggest problem that we've got
with Condominiums comes with
Condominiums whose members cannot get to
those meetings I no doubt in my mind um
I truly appreciate that I get to vote on
proxies for all those stocks and
companies that I own and uh now I get to
do it
online and
uh the Nuance is that some of my stocks
have split and divided and I have
multiple votes but at least it's easy
simple and I know my vote has been been
placed and I think this is a
wonderful change to our condo
statute thank
you okay John Cummings has yeah I got
John he's on the top of the list
here
okay
John my name is John Cummings I'm a
condominium owner in Freedom New
Hampshire I I sent my document to you I
wasn't sure if I can make it some not
sure if you haven't seen it at all but
for those of us who read our emails I
have absolutely seen it okay so passing
HB 11129 will prevent any condo owner
from having to fight for their voting
rights like I've had to for the past two
years I've been in a two-year battle
with our board of directors to be able
to vote via directed proxies as is
allowed under the current
statute this year I personally spent
over $6,000 in legal fees fighting our
board for the right to vote via directed
proxy and that $6,000 was spent to
resolve the matter outside of
court I was told take us to court by the
board and my lawyer wanted another 10 to
20 $10,000 retainer just to take it to
court and that probably would have cost
me quite a bit more than
that and to add insult to injury the
association attorney is on a recorded
board meeting saying directed proxies
are allowed but I still was not allowed
to cast vote via directed
proxy I contacted the Attorney
General representative Susan Aly and
several New Hampshire condo attorneys
and they all confirmed that directed
proxies were allowed under the current
statute
I presented our board with this
information and they still denied me the
right to vote via directed
proxies our board is emboldened by the
fact that condo owners have virtually no
recourse so once again I reached out to
Susan all me to propose changes before
us in
1129 that proposed J changes to statute
b39 make it clear that both directed and
undirected proxies are allowed under the
statute
uh please support HB 11129
thanks okay thank
you you good oh good
thanks okay uh we'll start with Gary
this
time okay uh thank you um not to uh
begin with a question but do you want
names of attorneys because now I now I
have some you got some um just please
give them to those ladies behind us okay
right we don't need to hear them okay I
okay you can set uh it would be great if
you email that to to me but yes but make
sure you get a copy for them okay and
I'm happy to to speak to the ladies
privately and and let them I have
appreciate being so Vigilant my request
sure I have uh four names so far okay
um okay this is
1129 the
proxies yes um so uh again I'm here for
uh Ci's legislative action committee and
as a committee having looked at this
bill we supported it because uh we
believe it provides some additional
Clarity to the existing law uh proxy are
already covered in existing law that is
true um but uh this particular bill um
doesn't try to Rel legislate the issue
and it doesn't create a conflict um it
really just seems to clarify which we
think is a good
thing
perfect thank you very much thank you
okay
Dean y he's left the
room uh he has a good couple of hours
drive okay so he left her all right
moving right along we close the public
hearing on 11:29
y okay we'll open up the public hearing
on 1645 representative
Aly yeah this one probably takes longer
um I
want this is something maybe you can
read at your
leisure but as I was eating lunch I
looked at my email and I had an email
from a woman who would be here if she'd
known about this several days
ago
well
all uh representative elme um Graft in
17 I think uh city of
Lebanon and
um you have those of you who' have been
on this committee before have
except for last term when it was
kidnapped by a senator
um and turned into something that was
totally
unrecognizable
um we um we've been putting this bill in
with more
refinements until 2020 when it passed
the
house and went into uh
Purgatory because right right after it
passed the house we all were sent home
to shut down for two weeks while covid
started to rage and when we got past the
two weeks we were told that everybody
else was shutting down
too so um the bill needed a public
Hearing in the Senate because they
needed to understand it better um they
were favorable to it we could have
passed it but it didn't happen and here
we are
again
and what it is about is how to enforce
violations of good
governance which means what the
condominium law says other state laws
might say uh what the Declaration that
everybody agreed to when they bought
their unit
says uh and the bylaws
that are created then or
after
um one of the problems that we have I
just wanted to mention first someone had
said something about we don't need any
more condominium law the problem is that
most of the
Declarations were written by the
developers and they were written with
requirements that
2third or 60% of the members had to vote
to approve a change in the
bylaws uh and that you can't approve a
change in the
Declaration but they
are the developer and his interests are
primary in that declaration and bylaws
and it didn't matter to the people
people in 1970 whatever it was uh that
wrote the first condominium
law
because at that time what they were
really worried about was corrupt
developers people that sold people lots
that didn't exist people that uh sold
people houses that were grade grade F
when when they' promised them grade
A or they' promised them not to put
another house right at their doorstep
and they did anyway
um so
um so it wasn't um they weren't thinking
about okay now you've got a condominium
which is volunteer people running AB
board this is what I started with when I
got into this 15 years ago or whatever
it was you've got volunteer people
running
aboard um maybe you've got a septic
system like we
do maybe you've got uh a lot of
roads that you have to fix every now and
then there's a whole lot of things that
are decisions of the
uh of
the condominium Group which are
equivalent to Decisions by the people in
in the
municipality but the Municipal
Association helps the boards of the
municipalities and the Town Council and
the and the the the city council or the
town Selectmen or the alderman it helps
them figure out how to govern gives them
trainings provides them guide books all
that kind of stuff so they really um the
people in the
condominium uh situation
only have the state
law and that makes things pretty
difficult this situation was solved for
manufactured
housing
in the beginning of the 90s or the 80s I
can't remember but they set up uh a
condomini a manufact a manufactured
housing
board and this spill is based on what
that manufactured housing board
did and what it did basically was to
have a group of people from all sides of
the of the trailer
parks uh plus a independent
lawyer as volunteers meeting on a
regular basis to look at
complaints and they would decide whether
the complaint was reasonable or
unreasonable fit into existing laws
somehow or didn't but they would
actually create law what they would do
is they would make a decision the lawyer
always wrote it um they would make a
decision and they would uh send it uh
they would do a synthesis of the of the
uh decision and they would put it in the
files of the superior court of that
County and it would sit in the superior
court
for uh six months I think it was uh and
if nobody appealed that decision from
the two
groups that were represented in the
trailer park they would um it would
become case
law and across the
state a judge that got a case from
people who were aggrieved about in a
trailer park would pull this this
decision out and say okay um this is
what that board decided and I I agree
with it or I don't agree with it but
they would use it as the basis of their
decision it would be a very short short
case uh and the judge could establish
remedies after that this is what were're
looking for in condominium law because
we can't put every little detail of
everything into the condominium law even
if then people would read it and the
boards would obey it we don't have an
enforcement
mechanism um I am really happy to say
that oh I also have this I hadn't handed
out I've got to get to amendments next
but I'm really happy to say that um some
of these amendments are because I was
contacted by the head of the Consumer
Protection Bureau in the AG's office and
um offered some things that they thought
should be fixed which this is a first
attempt this amendment um part of this
amendment to do that um so that the
legal procedure would go smoothly and
that then they would be willing to help
out in the past um they haven't had
enough Personnel in the AG's office and
please don't take this decision that we
ought to remove some of them again but
they haven't had enough of them so that
they could deal with
cases that
affected Condominiums they would just
when you when you called up they would
say we're sorry but you're going to have
to find a
lawyer finding a lawyer has been
extraordinarily difficult but um some
other people might mention that
and
uh
so the dispute that that's essentially
what that dispute board
does it it creates an efficient process
that takes most of the burden away from
the AG's office which isn't doing it
wasn't doing it at any rate I think
there's someone here from his office
who's going to to be speaking um
and I'll
just pass these amendments
out
oh I kept
one the first thing is on page
one uh lines 9 to
11 on this I add it on my own actually
uh three members of
or anyway um three members who are
resident unit owners not just owners of
Condominiums um that was from m co
conspirator uh
who who uh misread it as being possibly
saying on three members who were owners
of whole condom
um which would be for instance a
developer who still hadn't let go um but
neither I wrote in neither members
appointed under this subparagraph nor
their immediate household members shall
be members of their respective
condominium board that are in that
membership group for the board
um and then after that the filing fee
that we've been putting in is
$250 we didn't want it to be more than a
single individual with a really bad case
could afford to do but today with
expenses the way are they are and
frankly with what's been done to the
manufactured housing board um we thought
that it it ought to go up to
500 um but it's something that needs
hasn't been discussed for instance in my
cond of study committee which hasn't
been able to meet
enough
um and
then on page
three when we're looking at the
decisions and this is in response to
what um the head of the of the Consumer
Protection Bureau
um suggested to
me
um there are a number of of changes page
three line 8 the order uh when the board
makes its decision an order shall be
made in writing and shall include
findings of facts findings of facts
shall be accompanied by a concise and
explicit statement of the underlying
facts suround supporting the
findings um and I put in the order shall
include the actions that must be taken
by either or both parties to remedy the
complaint within a specific time frame
I'm not sure if that's the right
language that was what uh in response to
what um the uh
um
senior Assistant Attorney General
toally so brandan Brandon
Gard um and then Below in line 17 to
20 uh the dis first the existing languag
is a decision of the board may be
appealed by either party following a
request to for
rehearing by applying for an appeal to
the superior court of the County um if
no timely appeal is taken pursuant to
that paragraph the decision of the board
shall become final this is the part I
was talking to you about about it sits
with the superior court for a while and
after enough time is passed it is filed
as case
law uh but then I added um
four I guess I added four twice um in
the event that the decision of the board
is dis disregarded by one of the parties
and this is what we frequently get um
from just ordinary attempts of people to
help out and to get the board to do what
is in the the
rsas in the event it is disregarded by
one of the parties at any time after the
Certified Abstract of the decision is
filed with the court the grieved party
May appeal to the court for enforcement
and which point the court of the
Superior Court the judge of the Superior
Court May apply civil penalties
including fines and restitution leveled
on the condominium manager board members
or disruptive unit owner that might be a
little controversial but I felt that it
should not be levied on the condominium
because frequently the practice that
that one or 10 people are are um trying
to get stopped has been hurting
everybody else in the Condominium
Association too so that is what I came
up with but it's something to be
discussed the right of either and then
another four the right of either party
to separately file a lawsuit challenging
the final decision of the board shall
not be infringed in which case the board
shall be represented by the Department
of Justice the first part of that was um
um told me um sternly by Brandon Gard
the assist senior Assistant Attorney
General on the second part of it I
added because it only seems fair that
they should help out at that point but
that's another thing that may be
disputed um and then then the rest of
this is about the
fiscal note and what's we're likely to
be doing about the fiscal note uh the
manufactured housing board operated with
one Administrative
Assistant for 30 about 25 years before
they were starting to work themselves
out out of a job and they were operating
after that with about a tenth of a
person and
um there's no reason that this can't be
be done without what is now called a
board manager I
believe a board uh I've got it admin
board
administrator on but they gave us a
fiscal note that said that it is the
board administrator plus a lawyer plus a
um
researcher
board administrator investigator
prosecutor and hearings officer and each
of those grades gets more
expensive uh the board administrat by
themselves would be about $80,000 a
year and um that's what we need given
the structure we've got and I have an
appointment Thursday afternoon with the
head of um the office of professional
licenser and certification who I worked
with on a occasion in small ways um to
discuss the fiscal note which she could
not remember
so so I'm hoping that the fiscal note is
going to change
radically but on it also would require I
presume a board administrator position
labor grade 19 which is I've put in
there at the end as a kind of place
Setter for that so
that's that's all of the
Amendments that I've got
and I'm sorry I'm getting them to you
late and if anyone doesn't have one I
seem to I seem to have printed them out
twice
um maybe you want to did you give one to
Mr SC scura from the doj that might
forance testimony we have questions I
don't uh I saw representative Gibbs
hands first and then representative Bros
represent representative Gibs question
uh thank you uh let me just wait for
representative elme to sit back
down thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative elme um uh uh first of
all I want to thank you uh for
recognizing the fact that an employee
would probably be required and therefore
that an appropriation would be required
um we've had some bills that came before
us that were not so practical but I do
have a technical question um uh which
regards the language uh at the bottom of
page three uh where the final paragraph
deals with an annual report and um lines
uh 34 and 35 um uh says that the annual
report should uh should contain the
number of complaints received uh and the
number of complaints accepted and
rejected um I'm figuring that complaints
accepted means complaints accepted for
review by the board and rejected means
complaints that were were not accepted
for review by the board because they're
outside the board's purview but don't
you think that that should be followed
by some additional language requiring
that the report include the number of
complaints resolved or decided and the
number of complaints decided for or
against the
complainant shouldn't there be an
additional amendment to that effect that
that would probably be a very useful
thing to do
um okay
burs I would I'm sorry just um if I
could add to that um the complaints
would be rejected if they did not fit
within the language which is in here
about um on page two starting page line
19 uh that it we're talking about
failure by the Condominium Association
to follow its declaration in b laws
failure to follow proper voting
procedures as defined in
b39 uh RSA 356 b39 other actions not in
compliance with condominium instruments
or the Condominium
Act so uh there's something I call Pink
Flamingos which is a very frequent kind
of complaint uh in in
condominiums that you will allow
or um you allow one person to put plank
flamingos in their lawn and you don't
allow someone else to put put uh purple
ones and things like that things that
are are not related to the
governance you had a brief followup
representative Gibs thank you uh yes um
uh I think you and I are in agreement
about the meaning of of complaints
accepted or rejected
what I was suggesting is that some
additional information be required
regarding decisions that have been made
uh by the board so that the number of
decisions uh be reported and the number
uh of complaints decided for the
complainant or against the
complainant and maybe those that are
still in Pro the number that's still in
process yes all right and so we're we're
making suggestions
um so that would be a would you believe
right and this will go to a subcommittee
so uh perhaps you right two might want
to reach out and work out that detail
before the subcommittee representative
Bros okay thanks for taking my question
um I see in the fiscal note that they
are that the oplc was unable to estimate
how many condominium associations exist
in New Hampshire so I guess my question
is we don't know the number of
Condominiums how might we know the
number of of complaints that might get
in and therefore how do we know that we
need this um outlay of
$374,000 right well the
kai uh thinks that there are roughly one
uh uh one condominium unit for every six
people living in New
Hampshire I'm not so sure about that
because I think a bunch of them are
second owner Condominiums and they don't
live in New Hampshire most of them um
it's really hard to figure this out I've
been trying to talk with the wrong
people in the Census Bureau for a couple
of years now and I finally got told
which people to try and talk to that
they're in HUD but I haven't had time to
follow up um but that isn't the relevant
part the the word the most important
part of it is something we also don't
know which is how many condominium
associations are off the
rails
and there are an awful lot of
people well I shouldn't say an awful lot
of people among the the maybe two dozen
different groups of people that we've
heard from over the years that have
actually figured out that the
condominium study committee
exists uh there have been
uh they they all we find out about
because they gone off the
rails they're
disobeying our law they're disobeying
their
law uh sometimes they've actually
lost significant documents that could be
used
um
and and um
this that's how many the problem with
how many complaints are there going to
be first
you don't we don't have a method to
spread this around though if we had such
a board I think it would spread more
easily um partly
because the um consumer protection
Department would be telling them about
it uh
and but we have no idea how many there
there would be oh follow question so I
guess I guess the question is we don't
know how many complaints are going to
come in but yet we're we're suggesting
that there be a staff of four people for
$374,000 so I'm trying to wrap my head
around that well that's just the first
part of that that fiscal note problem
they don't need an investigator the
investigation gets done by people for
and against coming to the the board and
talking to
them and then perhaps a little bit of
factchecking by those
volunteers
um but a prosecutor there isn't going to
be a prosecutor it's the board and then
if the board is disregarded then it goes
to the court but it goes to the court
with the decision of the
board and which usually takes priority
but the judge gets to decide whether he
thinks that that board has gone off the
rails so it's an extra guideline in
there uh before the judge then decides
what he thinks appropriate penalty for
never giving minutes is so so quick
followup on that yeah and there's no
hearing office one more followup so are
you saying that we don't need any of
these people we need a board
administrator I don't know if they have
to be labor grade
but we don't know how many people are
going to complain but we need the board
administrator well the board
administrator well if they only get five
complaints that board administrator is
going to be doing something else in
oplc and the budget people are probably
going to have something to say with them
about it the next
time if we
get 100 complaints um in three
months then I I think that OPC is going
to be complaining a
little what happened in uh the old days
was that
the um manufactured housing Bo board had
taken um had been put into the oplc or
its predecessor I think it was called
something else then um
and and because the services that are
provided in
general uh the administrative services
for a board are um are needed to be put
somewhere and they do a good job of that
now I I have one question for you
represent Aly yeah
yeah uh the study committee to for
Condominiums
uh committee to study the laws relating
to condominium and homeowners
association I think reference that it's
been running since 2010 yes 20 the end
years the end of 2010 yeah this
legislation that you're proposing is
this a work product of that study
committee yes it is and how about the
amendment that you're proposing the what
how about the amendment that you're
proposing is that also the amendment uh
that I am proposing is just a work
product of me talking back and forth
with
uh the um
on Senor Assistant Attorney General uh
over the
weekend one more brief question let's
let's uh move on to the next uh but she
I understand Gib thank you uh just to
get back to representative Burrow's
question do I understand correctly that
um what you're proposing is a staff of
one not a staff of four yes EX exactly
thank you all right great thank you very
much for your testimony thank you we're
going to call up John John
cumins uh he has he supports the bill he
has written testimony and he's from
freedom and if you if you could limit
your remarks to just a few minutes that
would be appreci sure y my name is John
Cummings um an owner of a seasonal
condominium
Freedom the owners have virtually no
recourse at all to uh go after the
boards for these violations I've heard
that we can simply hire an attorney but
I fought the directed proxy issue and it
took me a long time to find an attorney
to fight for me I had I got a hold a few
attorneys that they agreed with my case
but they said they couldn't take it
because they would uh it would prevent
them for getting hired from boards for
doing work for board the board attorney
so our Board of director selectively
follows RSA 356 with a confidence that
they it is very unlikely that an owner
will challenge them in
court and they're also playing with
house money as opposed to an owner who
has to put up you know 10 or $20,000 up
his own pocket to take somebody to court
over an
issue and if they lose they might end up
paying the association's expense which I
think it's one of the RSB 34 maybe
whatever that is as we have to the loser
pays all fees so without a dispute
board we don't have much other help the
Attorney General won't
help
um I don't know what else to say about
that we need some something short going
to
court and less expensive than that to
resolve some
issues so please consider a support for
this Bill thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony any
questions all right seeing none thank
you very
much uh we have three from
Cai uh do you want to pick one member of
your team and
okay
and your name is
Gary didario all right and uh you you
oppose the bill and you ask for three
minutes hi yes um I will try to be uh
brief as Paul just mentioned we've uh
narrowed our group down from three uh
speakers to one um uh again uh we're
from Cai the legislative action
committee for um the New Hampshire
Branch uh CII is a National Organization
they're a nonprofit they exist solely uh
to make uh life in community settings
better um that is what they do on a
nationwide basis we would urge uh the
New Hampshire legislature to adopt what
their policy is on a national level
which is that Condominiums are
self-governing associations um um they
are not just allowed but obligated to
self-govern through condominium
instruments like the Declaration and the
bylaws and uh Ci's position is that uh
like so many other issues what a given
Association needs for a dispute
resolution process varies from
Association to Association so best to
let them make their own there's nothing
stopping any association from doing that
um I represent associations that have
such policies in place um I've been to
these types of meetings that occur on an
in-house basis and I can tell you that
they do work problems get resolved um in
a particular uh instance there was a
case that allowed because we were at the
association engaging in their in-house
process it allowed us to do something
that I don't even think could be done if
we were standing before some sort of
state agency or or state board uh it was
a noise issue between two neighbors and
uh the neighbors allowed us obviously
with their consent uh we went to the
units involved we stood in one unit went
outside went back in the other unit
turned on the TV and one turned on the
radio and another we went back and forth
and people were actually able to learn
what it sounds like when the the noise
comes through the wall uh the two
neighbors each felt that they got
somewhat of an education as to each
other's perspective and ultimately
through the exercise we identified the
volume levels uh that would be
acceptable uh within their devices and
the problem was resolved um again I I
don't think that type of um sort of
atome process or resolution could have
happened even if we were uh before a
state board just because we're no longer
at the condominium we don't have the
ability to do those sorts of things um
so largely uh we advocate for
Association being able to do this on
their own um to the extent uh if it is
the case that this legislature uh feels
that legislation is necessary uh we
think that the appropriate legislation
would be something similar to what has
been done with other issues where um the
Condominium Act says that the bylaws
shall
include and then a statement such as a
process for resolving disputes with the
unit owners um the the existing law says
that about other things and because the
law says that when these documents are
drafted these items are put in um our
other issues with this particular Bill
uh include the fact that it's not only
creating new government but with that
new cost and uh it's to me particularly
troubling that the new government would
be uh what I will call a oneway street
and I will explain um this new board not
withstanding that it would be a state
board would accept complaints from unit
owners about their Association but would
not accept complaints from Association
about a unit owner that's violating the
rules so even though it's a a sort of
segment of the New Hampshire state
government um it would only be catering
to the needs of sort of one side of the
equation and not the other which I think
from an equity uh perspective is
problematic other procedural issues that
we see are that this board would make an
initial determination about the merits
of a complaint without ever hearing from
the accused
Association and um this bill has come up
before and I've said this before but it
it Bears repeating I'll I'll provide an
easy example my theory is that in a
vacuum meaning if this board doesn't
receive any input from the accused
Association in a vacuum my theory is
that any complaint will sound
meritorious unless someone puts absolute
gibberish on a page and submits it if
you get no information from the accused
a complaint will always sound legitimate
uh now I'll give my example um the board
might receive a complaint from someone
that says I was recently denied at last
week's annual meeting my most important
in my most basic right as a condominium
unit owner I was denied the ability to
vote I went to the annual meeting I went
there in person my Association refused
to give me my ballot and as a result I
was unable to
vote on its own that sounds like a not
only a legitimate meritorious complaint
but a serious one at that um what I can
tell you is that it's not uncommon for
associations to have in their bylaws
that um certain rights and privileges
including voting at Association meetings
are dependent of on a unit owner being
in good standing with the
community good standing is often defined
as being both um in compliance with
whatever the association's rules and
restrictions are and up todate on
whatever the unit's Financial
Obligations are to the
association and so in the example I just
gave it sounds out of hand without any
information from the association like a
very meritorious complaint but if the
association
were allowed to provide some information
and said our documents say you need to
be in good standing this person that was
denied the ability to vote hasn't paid a
condominium fee in 14 months that's why
they weren't able to vote it's all in
our documents then that changes
everything and so the point of that
example is just to sort of highlight the
importance of if such a board were to
exist even if such a board were to only
operate as a one-way Street meaning that
they only accept complaints from unit
owners and not from the association it
still only makes sense
procedurally for this board to get some
form of input from the accused
Association before they make any
decisions even if it's a preliminary
decision about the merits of the
complaint I don't really know of another
instance in any sort of legal or even
pseudo legal setting where you have you
know an accused
and the accused and the accused provides
no information um I know that they
anticipate that happening later uh but
again it's problematic for all involved
if this committee is reading you know
complaints in a vacuum and deciding that
everything has Merit and then everything
that comes in goes forward and there's
going to be a lot of hearings before
these boards I know associations we've
talked about board members um they're
not going to appear without legal
represent presentation they just won't
do it they're volunteers they feel
strained as it is um and they're not
going to subject themselves to something
like that so in terms of expense I don't
think that there's necessarily a real
savings um it was mentioned that the fee
for this new board is anticipated to be
in the neighborhood of
$250 um that is within 25 to $30 of the
fee for filing a court case and if a
unit owner wanted to file a case against
their Association and represent
themselves they are entitled to do that
um and again if they got their attorney
and this a point that was made earlier
in the day um but if a unit owner got an
attorney went to court proved a case and
one section 15 Roman numeral 2 would
allow them to recover their legal costs
so um you know all told we we just don't
think there's that compelling uh of
reason for the state to add government
and add expense um if it does we would
hope that it wouldn't be a one-way
Street and uh again finally even if it
is a one-way Street we would hope um
that this board would at least take some
information in from the accused before
anything else is done but generally
speaking um I think a better approach
for this legislature would be if
anything uh to Simply put into the law
that a dispute resolution process at the
cond minum is something that needs to be
in their
bylaws all right thank you very much for
your testimony representative Gibbs you
have a
question thank you I do um and thank you
for taking my question um you refer to
uh preferring a an in-house uh dispute
resolution system and you gave an
example of a dispute between two
neighbors but but if the dispute were in
fact between the board and uh an
individual unit owner but
the complaint had to be resolved if the
statute provided that the complaint had
to be resolved in house wouldn't that be
providing that the board would be
allowed to adjudicate complaints against
itself um so potentially in the first
instance um I do still think it matters
because it does change the process in
other words what we've heard here today
uh from unit owners who have had issues
um we've heard um repeatedly that the
property management company doesn't
listen to me they don't give me the time
of day um the board they don't listen to
me they don't give us the time of day so
if the in-house process even if it just
mandated that the board um have a
meeting with the unit owner hear theit
unit owner out on what their issues are
um it would still be some form of
forward progress because there would be
more happening um than than what is
happening right
now forther question may inquire thank
you um we've heard several discussions
today about what happens if there's
something in the statute and the board
just doesn't do it what if it's in the
statute and the board just doesn't do
it so
unfortunately that question could be
raised of anything I mean we have uh any
number of laws in the state on both the
Civil side and the criminal side and
there are those people who choose to
break those laws every single day um in
in all kinds of areas regardless of what
the law is and um you know we have what
we have we have a system of laws and we
have a system uh where we have the
judicial uh courts in place uh for
people to go to with their issues
um you know when when we talk about any
of these items that question sort of
remains in other words earlier today we
were talking about a piece of
legislation that said well the board
should give minutes promptly and we had
a discussion about the fact that the law
already requires boards um to to give
minutes and the question became well
what happens if the board doesn't follow
that law well um if we passed the bill
that we were discussing today and we add
added to the law an additional sentence
that said that uh meeting minutes must
be provided
promptly a board that's going to break
the law could just as easily break that
law um as any other on the books and so
I I think that we're not going to
prevent regardless of of what statute
we're talking about or or what Bill
we're talking about I don't think we can
legislate our way into full compliance
because there will always be those
people who choose
uh to to not follow the law or to break
the law I think for those cases what we
have to rely on are are the recourses
that exist in our
system so representative Gibs you'll be
happy to know the answer of this
question you just pose is about to be
answered thank you very much for your
testimony you're welcome chair will call
on Kevin Sora from the Department of
Justice
good afternoon sorry to keep you waiting
oh no worries uh my name is Kevin scura
I'm an Assistant Attorney General in the
consumer protection and antitrust Bureau
over at the Department of Justice um I
want to clarify that I'm not speaking
either in favor or against
uh the legislation um neither is my
office nor the Attorney General taking a
position on the legislation uh the
purpose of the testimony today is simply
to to point out um a couple of potential
technical issues that have the potential
to cause confusion or or make it
difficult for the bill to accomplish the
purposes that it sets out to
accomplish um and some of this uh cover
some of the ground that was addressed in
the the amendment that was discussed a
little earlier um and so I guess you
know to some extent it may be um talking
about the same same issues as as the
amendment uh I think the first first
issue I'd like to talk about is uh the
authority of the board um the current
draft of the legislation you know before
the amendment I think to some extent
even after the amendment um doesn't uh
address what types of relief that the
board will be able to off off
order um and so the you know the
legislation contemplates that the board
might be able to um order order parties
to take actions in the amendment or you
know before that to you know enter a
decision that will go to the Superior
Court it doesn't clarify what kinds of
relief uh the board can can award um and
so you could you think about a court
that can or injunctive relief or damages
or penalties or costs um and you know a
board might wish to do any one of those
things in in different cases but it's
not clear from the current text of the
draft uh whether has the power to do
that and you know again I'm not taking a
position on you know which of those
Powers if any would be appropriate for
the board uh just pointing out that the
the current draft doesn't really specify
which Powers it has uh which could lead
to a challenge to any board
action that that's
taken um second you know the draft
legislation leaves unclear uh you know
what effect uh it has on the
jurisdiction of the Consumer Protection
Bureau um um the the the amendment
addresses this issue with respect to the
Superior Courts um the the draft
legislation before the amendment also
had a a question an open question of
what the effect would be on the
jurisdiction of the Superior Courts the
amendment addresses that issue um but
leaves the issue of you know what what
effect it would have on the jurisdiction
of the Consumer Protection Bureau um as
it's in effect today the Condominium Act
provides that the uh provisions of the
ACT shall be ad administered and
enforced by the consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau um and the current
draft legislation states that the board
can accept complaints against
condominium
associations uh that are forwarded by
the Consumer Protection Bureau but
doesn't clarify um what effect that
forwarding mechanism would have on the
the Consumer Protection Bureau whether
the the bureau would be able to bring
its own action if it if it saw fit to do
that um and as currently drafted uh the
legislation could lead to to challenges
um to action by The Bureau um and the
the the outcome of a challenge like that
would not be
clear uh next you know the um draft
legislation provides for a filing fee
that will be required for complaints
that are filed with the board um and
also provides that the complaints can be
forwarded from the bureau to the board
uh but doesn't specify whether the
filing fee would apply to the forwarded
complaints who would be uh responsible
for for paying it um so the committee is
aware there's currently no fee to file a
complaint with the consumer protection
and antitrust Bureau uh and so if sort
of left as it is it could create an
incentive for unit owners to file
complaints with the bureau in the hopes
that they would be forwarded on to the
to the board uh and thereby avoid the
filing fee um the draft legislation also
provides uh that you know people who are
filing complaints have to give 10 days
notice to the opposing party and that
the board has a mechanism to you know
dismiss complaints if it finds the claim
to be frivolous or without Merit um it's
also not clear how those procedures
would apply in the case of complaints
that were forwarded from the bureau so
if the bureau got a complaint and
forwarded it to the board does the board
still have the the power to uh dismiss
the complaint if it finds it frivolous
or without Merit um also who is
responsible for providing notice is it
the the bureau or the complainant um in
in the case of
forwarded uh complaints
and sort of on the topic of of frivolous
um uh our Bureau receives complaints
against Condominiums and many of those
complaints involve uh disputes around
things like access to documents uh or
adherence to you know aesthetic rules of
Condominiums like paint colors or yard
maintenance and uh you know I'm not
taking a position on whether those
complaints are are frivolous or not um
you know they may not have statewide
impact they certainly do invoke strong
feelings uh you know one potential
benefit of a board like this may be that
it could provide a form to resolve those
kinds of disputes but um the committee
may wish to provide a little more
guidance on what counts as a frivolous
complaint um as it's considering the
legislation
um I had a note on the defined term
usage which I I think uh the amendment
addressed about the distinction between
condominium owners and condominium unit
owners um next I wanted to note that the
legislation the draft legislation
selects two different parts of the
Department of Justice to serve roles in
relationship to the board um which it
requires the bureau chief for the
Consumer Protection Bureau to direct the
board's rulemaking process and then uh
requires the Civil Division to act as
Council to the board uh there may be
good reasons to do that um but I did
want to note that it would you know
require sort of uh attorneys from
different parts of the of the office to
develop expertise in in the same area um
and that leads into the final point I
want to make which is uh the potential
fiscal impact of the legislation on the
the uh Department of Justice this is
covered in the department of Justice's
fiscal note um but because it would
require the bureau chief of the Consumer
Protection Bureau to act as to direct
the board's rulemaking and the Civil
Division to act as Council um it could
you know require increased Staffing at
the Attorney General's office depending
on the length and complexity of the
rulemaking process and uh you know how
many complaints uh the board receives
and how much how involved that work
winds up being uh which could affect the
consumer escrow account and the general
fund but at this at this point without
knowing how long those tasks will take
it's impossible to estimate what the
fiscal impact of the bill would be um I
thank the committee for its time and I'm
happy to answer any
questions now represent
Gibs thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
for taking my question uh regarding the
testimony that was provided um by the
previous
witness that it would be um Pro
problematic if the board were to make a
decision based only on information
provided by the complainant considering
the fact that the bill itself states
that someone from the AG's office would
would advise the board wouldn't that
person from the AG's office advise the
board that due process would require
that the board in investigating a
complaint hear from both
parties well I
I'm not sure I can answer what sort of
constitutional due process might require
I you know recall that the bill sort of
contemplates uh you know rulemaking
which you know may address whether any
sort of procedures what the procedures
may be in a sort of prehearing process
uh in a prehearing motions process which
may or may not I mean certainly that's
where in many situations you do see um
an opportunity for for response from an
accused party further question me
inquire thank you just a follow-up
question okay putting aside
constitutional issues wouldn't General
wouldn't you advise if you were advising
the board on behalf of the AG's office
that General fairness would require
receiving information for both
parties I mean certainly the the
legislation as it it currently has has
been
drafted um contemplates a a hearing and
I think the know talks about rulemaking
which would talk about you know a
pre-trial process and you know to me a
pre-trial process would involve uh I
mean in a court you'd call it a motion
to dismiss I don't know you know what it
would be called in this situation but
something like
that you're all set so have you guys
done rules
before consumer protection Division I
don't I don't remember the consumer
protection division did uh draft the
rules for the Condominium Act and for
the land cell registration act when the
orig the original rules and we we have
to update them every 10 years in
accordance with the administrative
procedure act but if someone were to
call up with a complaint and say what
you know uh what is you what are what
can you do for
me uh you know I I would say that
consumer protection division is normally
is to we try to make you whole you know
restitution and or uh or try to order
the merchant or wherever it was to cease
and toist well obviously you're not
going to order a cease and toist here in
this case or no way so what what exact
actly could you do to help a consumer uh
get this case resolved even if without
this statute on the boat
so um at the Consumer Protection Bureau
we receive complaints against all kinds
of businesses including condominium
associations right um you know every
written complaint that we receive in
attorney reviews uh we ask the uh
consumer for the permission to send the
complaint to the business assuming they
Grant it we send the complaint to the to
the business and get their resp response
um and then from there we make a
decision about you know sometimes a
letter on the Attorney General's
letterhead uh can uh resolve it can
resolve the situation sometimes it
doesn't um and you know we make a
decision then about whether to pursue an
investigation or possible litigation
have you ever done any litigation have I
personally done litigation no I'm saying
has the has the office ever done any
litigation on a condo has has it done
litigation in response to a complaint
against
aware but you find find out is that
possible you can sure give us a little
case
law um I I could find out whether that
we've ever taken an action against the
condo board based on a complaint from a
unit owner right okay question all right
representa
Amon thank you Mr chair and thank you
attorney scuro for taking my question
um just want to understand uh why this
makes sense under the office of
professional
lenser uh I see that their fiscal note
uh was the the
largest um and uh near the end of the
bill it says uh the office of
professional lure and
certification the administration of the
condominium dispute resolution board is
uh inserted under their Authority so if
you have any any thoughts on that would
you please
share um I I was not aware of that until
I got to the hearing today um I'm not
I'm not certain why why it would be that
way I mean I you know the Condominium
Act uh assigns to the Consumer
Protection Bureau the the authority and
I guess duty to enforce the the Act and
the jurisdiction of resolving disputes
about it to
the uh Superior Courts um so I'm I'm not
sure what role the the oplc would play
but I Al candidly have not researched
the
issue any other
questions great thank you very much
thank
you uh okay so I'm GNA call you
separately so this time
Katie
play no you are not bad at
all I know some puer is from New Jersey
so that's how I can pronounce your name
no
relation
um all right sorry
um you've heard me talk many times
already um if there was a resolution
board I wouldn't have to be here um
because as you've heard
I've got a rogue board in
management um and I'd be able to seek
their assistance um as far as the whole
somebody not being able to or go to an
annual meeting and vote and because they
weren't in good standing there could be
you know a questioner that you know
you're submitting this in you're paying
these maybe they should also have to
require um a condo um a current condo
fee
statement um you know so they so it
those questions can be you know taken
care of um the financial standpoint of
putting that up you know 35k is just a
number um you know is there going to be
a lot or less um you know why these
things can be Revisited in a yearly
basis you know if there's more or less
that need to be done um as far as the
AG's office sorry um I called the AG's
office I've called the consumer Division
I was told sure fill out this form but I
don't know who I'm going to give it
to you don't you know I have a
reasonable
accommodation um issue for my son I
called them asked them builded it out
and they said you'd have I'm like I need
help like I'm not getting any ANW aners
this has been going on for 6
months and they said go ahead fill this
out and you know what I don't know where
I'm going with that but they said you
should call you know the disabilities um
lawyer or something um because you'd get
a better response from them that's
really sad if I can't even get help from
the attorney general so I guess that's
all I got to say is I'm
supportive any
questions okay thank
you uh dick
sweat this time you wrote dick this time
right you sure you're not an
ambassador you're not the
Ambassador
I've been up here before so I will not
introduce myself dick sweat straight of
New Hampshire on uh HB 1645
FN uh the condominium Leadership Council
and the vineyard board of directors
opposed this bill for the following
reasons RSA 356 b35 States the
condominium bylaws were to be written
providing for the self-government of the
condominium by an association of unit
owners HB 1645 would allow a unit owner
to petition the dispute board directly
and not follow any complaint procedures
prescribed in the association's bylaws
HB 1645 is contrary to the principle of
an association's right of
self-government the appointed dispute
board would substitute the wisdom of
elected Association boards who have a
vested interest in their Association is
compared to appointed Outsiders who
really don't have any knowledge of a
specific Condominium Association HB 1645
provides for final Relief by the appeals
to the Superior Court this is the same
court that would decide a case without
the burdens and expense required by
appearing before the resolution board HB
1645 will provide the resolution of
disputes and will add an unnecessary lay
uh layer of legal processes and what
penales can the dispute board levy on a
party who does not comply with the
dispute
board's decision if canding owners are
not happy with the elected board's
governance and management practices the
remedy is for the owners to participate
in the association's governance by being
elected to the association's board of
directors paragraph 356 b73 parag 3C
statement that this is the statement
from this
uh issue we're looking at here the
statement says the board meaning the
dispute board shall not be bound by
common law or Stat statutory Rules of
Evidence but may admit all testimony
having a reasonable probative value and
this to me is a description of an
autocratic Tribunal the office of
professional lure and certification will
oversee the dispute board for the uh
oplc to fulfill its duties under H
1645 the estimated cost is
$374,000 I would also point out that
this uh uh board is modeled after the
manufactured housing board and if you go
to the manufactured housing board uh
they do have a website and you can look
at their meeting and board and agendas
and they only they only have two years
up
2021 they
had gee I don't know maybe four hearings
and I think they were like preliminary
hearings and they might have had one
actual resolution hearing and in
2022 I don't think they had any hearings
and I think they might have one or maybe
one and in 2023 there were no posting
whatsoever so I don't know how many
manufactured housings are around here
but the percentage of those folks
availing themselves of that dispute
board is
minimal
um we actually repealed it P pardon
we've repealed that it's doesn't exist
anymore it doesn't it doesn't even exist
anymore no and the reason it doesn't
exist uh that's well I'll tell you
offline okay well I just kind of curious
you know that's it's important
um let me
see
well I I would say in this resolution
here it basically does say that the
Attorney General will represent this
board that would mean to me that anybody
who comes before this board is probably
also going to have an attorney pres so
no matter whether you're going before
this board and have any attorneys or you
go to the Superior Court where the final
resolution is going to be anyway you're
going to be dealing with
attorneys well I think that's really all
I have I will say that these are all
dealing with civil penalties uh
certainly if they're criminal penalties
we're dealing with a different can of
worms but these are all civil penalties
so that is all I
have and thank you very much thank you
and I hope you enjoyed your day here and
I am coming back as a matter of fact
you're going to come back with our sub
coming back this is really been I've
really enjoyed this that's even more fun
you know I've learned an awful lot about
this whole organization and group I
really have maybe you want to run for
office coming to be ion maybe you want
to run to be a state r no no no no no
no I'm I I I'm not qualified I'm not
qualified for
that don't ask us for our
qualifications right right and all you
have to do is be willing to work for 100
bucks a
year Ashley you get the last
word
so you've heard from me before Ashley
ten from marac New Hampshire um this is
probably the fifth or sixth time that
this bill has come up before you guys in
multiple different drafts and in
multiple multiple different ways um and
if it's continuing to come up then cases
are continuing to come to the committee
um that writes these up and if that's
happening then there is definitely a
need for this um you
know
if if I didn't do some Googling I
wouldn't even have known about the
committee and it's not easy to find you
there is no thing out there that just
says hey if you're having an issue with
your condo go here take a look at this
everything is go to your board so you go
to your board you don't get any
resolution you go to your management
company they say go to your board you
don't get any
resolution then you go to the Attorney
General's office you fill out a
form months go by you don't hear
anything you call oh yeah we received
your form we're not sure how we're going
to handle that because we don't have the
staff it's just it's an over and over
thing and then you eventually just get
told either by your association's lawyer
or your management company or your board
itself you know what you want this fixed
soon
us so then you're spending your money
and it's anywhere from $6 to $122,000
for a
retainer I'm sorry but I don't know of a
whole lot of people that are living in
condos that have $6 to $12,000 to put
down for a retainer to go to a lawyer to
then take time out to go to court to
then hopefully be able to get that money
back this dispute board will cut all of
that um and there's definitely a need
there are rogue Boards out there I would
love to find a place that has a good
board that follows every single law and
if we went through the whole process of
well why are we going to build this
board why are we going to do these laws
if you know they're not going to be
followed well why do we pass any law if
it's not going to be followed there are
criminals everywhere and we continue to
pass laws and we continue to have courts
that hear that but for condos it's
different you go to your board and then
you're told to sue them you don't want
to sue the place that you live you want
to be able to enjoy the place you live
having a dispute board to be able to go
to hear this without having to go to
court or take money out or try and get a
lawyer that you know as you just saw
earlier today it's not easy to find a
lawyer that's going to do
this um you know and I appreciate you
getting us those names but it's still
it's not easy for a homeowner owner to
bring up a complaint against the board
and I'm saying that as a former board
member and as a homeowner you know we
hear a lot of homeowner complaints some
of them are homeowner versus homeowner
some of them are people not happy with
the management company some of them are
people not happy with the other board
but unless you've got something that's
going to mitigate that and be that
middle person almost like a
mediator um type thing
you're not going to get anywhere and
like I said the fact that this is
continuing to come up and that people
are continuing to go to this committee
to say that there are issues with the
laws or that there's issues with their
boards and that boards are not following
this law and that we are following the
due process of going to our board our
management company the AG's office and
then having to try and find a lawyer
just the fact that they're continuing to
hear this and that this Bo this bill
keeps coming before you guys there's an
issue here and it needs to be addressed
thank
you and thank you for
coming okay having no more
cards speak more all right we will close
the public
hearing and stay tuned for the
subcommittee I think this this is an
early bill so we will be subbing this
fairly
soon
so we
that well it's cuz you're F me saying
overnight
right